Alhamdulillah.
We thank Allah subhana wa ta'ala
and we praise Allah subhana wa ta'ala and we are utterly humbled by the grace and
the mercy of Allah subhana wa ta'ala upon us that he makes us from the ranks
of the muslim from those who
sayahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahillah muhammad roo and we are blessed and honored from being to
for Allah's blessing upon us to be from those who are the followers of sah Muhammad
saiam
every one of us should feel the overwelm helming blessing of being a follower knower a
lover of Sah Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam should never be lost on us
we should never be
uh oblivious to this fact it's very easy to forget
it's very easy to get caught up in your life in your circumstances in your routines
and neglect the fact that Allah blessed us with the reality the of Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam. These salawat that I just did, these are these are the the the the true
key
uh into a a beautiful and profound connection to Allah and his messenger Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam. Allah is the one who commanded us.
And he says that he himself alongside the angels send salawat upon Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
Oh you who believe
sendawat
upon
and
give him salutations.
And so inshallah let us never forget to be from the people of salawat.
The blessings of salawat are endless.
Truly they will open up all doors for you in life.
And this is not just a claim.
This is a truth a
that is gifted to us from the sacred tradition that if you are person of salawat
if you make an abundance of sending salutations and prayers and peace upon sau Muhammad sallallaihi
wasallam then Allahh will suffice your affairs.
He will take care of your matters
through the salawat.
And those who send salawat upon Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam they will have the
of Muhammad sallall alaihi wasallam.
And those who do salawat upon Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam that relief,
success, victory is brought through the salawat.
And so
sending salawat upon the prophet wasallam is an entire institution a very sacred one
that we have to be far more intimately connected and familiar with inshallah.
So may Allahh bless this gathering for us through the blessings of the salawat.
And inshallah all of our intentions for being here is very clear.
We are gathered and our teachers would teach us this.
When you gather together in a gathering like this the intention is to worship Allah subhana
wa ta'ala. The intention is to learn and connect to our sacred tradition.
The intention is to fall in love with Allah and his messenger Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
The intention is to emulate the way of Sah Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
The title of this gathering based on the book that we're reading is how to live
like the prophet.
And this is taken from the guidance of Allah subhana wa
ta'ala
that verily in the the in the prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam do you have the
most excellent and beautiful of guides for those who desire the pleasure of Allah and desire
the felicity of the afterlife.
So that is only found
you can only find
the of
the virtues of both worlds this one and the next in the extent to which you
emulate Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
So I want you that a part of our intention when we're sitting here is that
I'm listening to these narrations these transmissions around the prophetam because I want to emulate I
want to mimic
I want to be what he is sallallahu alaihi wasallam this is not just you know
casual learning you know like you are interested in woodworking so you go to Home Depot
and you take a casual sun Saturday morning you know how to measure and cut wood
or This is more
about
emulating the best of Allah's creation to being living in tandem with him sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
So we seek to walk the way he walked to eat the way he ate to
speak the way he spoke to live the way he lived to gesture the way he
gestured to to be inwardly and outwardly who he is sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
So that's a part of the critical nia of this class.
Probably the most essential intention after attaining the pleasure of Allah is that
ya
gift us the sacred learning that will help us be truly representative beings in the way
of sah Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam that we emulate him.
That's what we want
is that that is the epitome of why you exist in this earth in the first
place as a Muslim.
If you're a conscious believer, subhan Allah, just
yesterday guy was one of these medical professionals came to our house to
do some draw some blood for my mom for some treatment she has to do.
And uh my mother's like, you know, can you stay around us?
I said, sure, no problem.
Of course. So, I'm listening to the guy talk and he's just, you know, chatting, chatting,
chatting. And then he goes, uh, so are you guys um you guys are Muslim?
She's like, "Yeah."
And he's and he said, "Oh, your children are Muslim, too?"
And so my mom's like, "Yeah."
And she's like, "And and they're all practicing
Muslims." I was like, "Yeah."
He's like, "That's a good thing.
That's a good thing cuz, you know, you need morality in this day and age.
You can't just be, you know, someone who doesn't believe in God.
That's where all the problems are coming from.
You got to believe in God.
And and, you know, it's good that your children are practicing.
And did you force them to practice or they're just like practicing on their own?"
And she's like, "No, my,
you know, they practice on their own."
Um, subhan Allah.
But this, I mean, I just, you know, it was so casual, but it struck me.
I said, you know, the power of having having
a moral compass, the power of living for
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala, for a being that is far greater than you, your creator, your
sustainer. It cultivates humility.
when you are a follower of Sah Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam a true servant of God
he is the truest representation of servantthood sallallahu alaihi wasallam and that's what we tried to
capture this Ramadan in the series called the servant prophet
um the idea of it was to emulate the truest representation of
servantthood the prophet Muhammad sallall alaihi wasallam he embodied the truth
ofman
and the servants ofman
are those who walk gently on this earth.
You see today so much of the death and destruction, the pain and the suffering, the
brutalization, the just absolutely dark brutalization that is being inflicted upon the people in Falstine.
May Allah bring them endless
relief.
But you just see that there there is a soullessness behind it.
A soullessness. It's
no consideration for humanity, for the human condition, for certainly not what God loves or wants
or likes or any of the prophets of God.
It's just complete and utter
chaos.
And subhan Allah, you think to yourself, how far removed is that from
those who walk gently on earth?
As Allah says, and the servants of the most merciful are those who walk gently on
this earth.
So brothers and sisters, this is um you know studying books like these and living in
the sacred
realm of the house of Allah and coming together as a community to do this.
You should take this on as a mission, as a journey, as a purpose of of
your existence, not just
a gathering for casual learning and some nice spicy chicken.
Alhamdulillah, that was good.
May Allah bless you.
We'll take the we'll take the good food.
Alhamdulillah and the good company.
But I hope the intention is clear that there's a higher order purpose for our company
here inshallah. So with that, let us
begin.
Uh if you don't have the book, you can I think you can
you can purchase the book if you want to purchase it on the uh the
entrance. I am going to be continuing
from
Muhammad. From what I understand, I am at on page 29
beginning from the fifth section.
So if you have the book page 29
at the um the fifth
section
inul
I lost the one second.
Give me a moment.
No, that's not
it.
I'm just opening up the Arabic and I I I seem to have
lost it for a
second.
You can do some salawat as we're waiting.
Get some baraka.
There we
go.
So
in the fifth section
he is in the section of
The author of this book is the great scholar of Syria
Abdah
Husseini where he says in the fifth uh point around gentleness and
ease
he
says
that from gentleness is
um from kindness and
gentleness is
making matter is easy and not making them difficult.
So he
says
Muhammad. So a uh nomad a desert nomad entered into the mosque of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam and he urinated in the mosque upon which those present rose up to deal
with him
i.e to castigate him and you know go at him pretty
strongly. And the prophet sallall alaihi wasallam said leave him
leave him be
and pour a bucket full of water
over his urine for indeed and then he this is the objective.
He gave them the command and then he indicated the objective of this command.
He says, "For indeed
you have been commissioned to make matters
easy,
and you have not been commissioned to make matters difficult."
So, subhan Allah, this is a very powerful
uh indication of what the what the reality of
of gentleness actually is
that it manifests so profoundly that there's a man who walks into the masid, urinates, and
the prophetam says, "Leave him."
And another narrations he don't cut his urine meaning don't stop him midstream and let him
relieve
himself. Let him relieve himself because you were not
sent
you were not commissioned and sent except to bring
ease
and not to bring hardship.
So a part of the ease when the when the when they explore what does it
mean that he that we are sent to bring ease in this particular context
is
if you were to get up and castigate him you would shame him.
It would harm him.
We don't do that.
If you would get up if you would get up to
deal with him as you're claiming to want to do or or you know to do
then you would cut off his his urine and that means you would affect him physically.
You would harm him physically.
If you were to do what you want to do, you perhaps may shame him in
a way that would exile him from the community that he would rush away, he would
leave the space.
So there's so many
indications of what the prophetam is saying when he
says
you were sent
with and commissioned to bring ease
because
is
it is the the the noun of the
actor
here is
that means that your identity when you think of yourself as a believer is
you bring ease.
So here he's teaching the community of believers that they're watching something very
uh if you will egregious happening right in front of them and he's tempering them and
conditioning them saying hey you were sent to bring ease you were not sent to bring
hardship. So
check your attitude, check your approach, check your speech, check your habits, check your behaviors.
How are you going to deal with him?
No, leave him
be
and then we will address it.
It's not to say that
is saying there's no moral standard because that's where people they get it wrong.
They think, oh, there's no moral standard.
Let people do whatever it is they want to do and who cares.
That's not what he's saying.
He's not saying live and let live.
That's how that's the modern ethos.
You know, do whatever you want to do as long as you're not bothering me.
Do whatever you want to do.
That's not what he's saying.
He is going to
bring in the education.
He's going to bring in the guidance.
He's going to teach him.
But the way he's going to do that
is by ensuring that he the man feels
well, safe, secure, at ease, comfortable and then he guides him.
So when the man was done and the prophet sallallaihi wasallam told the companions, go and
pour water
over the urine.
Pour the water over it.
And then the prophetam sat down with the man.
He said, "Please welcome.
Come." Like as if the man was just like taking off his shoes and putting them
in the shelf.
and the prophet was waiting for him to like just wrap up or he was having
a quick meal and he was going to come and sit down.
That's literally the attitude towards a man who was urinating in the masjid.
Okay, now that he's done and you're done and you're relieved, please sit down.
We don't do that.
That's not the way of treating the house of Allah.
This is the house of Allah.
He taught him.
He guided him.
He guided him to that which is best.
He's the prophetam was sent
as a
guide
a guide to the straight path.
So he's going to guide him but it's the method and the approach and the means
of guidance that is in order here.
So when the prophetam says to the companions because the idea
of
is synonymous with
the prophets the prophets
are
they are the ones who are commissioned and sent from God.
But now the prophetam is saying you as my
inheritors because he would say about
himself
when he would use the language of bath that I was commissioned and sent to perfect
character. I was sent as mercy.
I was sent as such.
And we have many descriptors of the prophet in that vein.
But now he's telling us
You were sent
and commissioned to bring ease and not to bring
hardship. And so the conception of religion and we're going to spend some time here because
I want to make sure we get this very right
because I'm going to say a disclaimer from now.
Whenever people start talking about
religion of Islam i.e.
as ease,
the purpose of religion is ease.
There are misconceptions here.
People act sometimes as if these a hadith don't exist.
So they're like a hammer everywhere they go.
They're just like, you know,
smashing people's heads all the time.
Religion is like a blunt
uh
force
uh instrument. And then there are those who act as if this hadith or these sayings,
and we're going to get into a few of them now,
effectively say,
um, religion is easy.
Do whatever you want.
God cares about what's in your heart.
Full stop. So we live in the world of like very violent spectrums
extremes extremes of religion as like no smiling harshness loud aggressive you know
very um
hurtful like it's very
punishmentoriented very uh fire and brimstone oriented and that's an extreme that's rejected and then the
other extreme that's rejected is the idea that oh it's all ease
do whatever you want you know what I mean religion is easy
i.e be whatever your nef's desires, whatever your lower self desires, as long as you're happy,
that's what religion is.
No, these are two rejected extremes.
So, we want to live somewhere in the middle, inshallah.
And hopefully we'll have that clarified for us with these
hadith.
So,
also we said that
The prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam says in the
narrated Bkari Muslim on the authority of an
he said sallallahu alaihi wasallam make matters easy
and do not make them difficult give good tidings glad tidings and do not drive people
away.
So your objective once again direct command from the prophet
sallallam make things
easy
don't make things
hard
bring glad tidings inspire people through glad tidings and do not
drive people
away
is when you dispose yourself in a way where people just can't stand you they don't
want to be around you
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam That which was so evidently inviting about him that made people
fall in love with him were his
his character, how he spoke, how he was that he was
that he was the truthful one and the honest one, you know, trustworthy one sallallahu alaihi
wasallam. And so people were naturally inclined to him because of his good character, his gentleness,
his kindness.
And so that at the essence of your conception of religion has to be that spirit.
Once again, that doesn't mean we're not principled.
That doesn't mean we don't have fault lines.
That doesn't mean that, you know, there are no standards.
That's not the case at all.
However, the spirit let's talk about the governing spirit is one
of
when Allahh says in the Quran
you
read
Allah
in divine revelation in the
spirit of it the purpose and this is obviously nestled within the ayat
of
Ramadan in
Bakar
may Allah accept our Ramadan
and may he gift us many more Ramadan
He is saying to us, Allah wants ease for us.
Allah is telling us, I want ease for
you.
So don't you ever conceive of religion in the language of hardship or difficulty.
Conceive of religion, conceive of your
identity as a devout servant in the spirit of
ease.
That's because that's what Allah wants for you.
And so therefore then if we understand this about the spirit
of our sacred tradition then that's what we have to
embody.
Meaning that if some of us we were raised with a religious discourse that's very
harsh
intense very aggressive very absolute you know
and it was it was always under the threat of
punishment. Salah was under the threat of punishment.
reading the Quran under the threat of punishment.
If you don't, God will smite you.
God will this, God will that.
Making it where your the spirit around the religious discourse is what
is one of
one of
u
harshness and aggressiveness.
That becomes the spirit of
it.
It's almost like you're being bullied
into devotion.
Now you the parent may have technically been saying the correct thing like the correct thing
is that you should pray technically like in terms of like a line item
technically yes
but the approach the spirit the dispensation is all wrong it's flawed it's not the way
of sah Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam if the average philosophy of religious discourse that exists today
was prevalent in front of in the time of the
prophetam right and that man urinated.
Guess what that what would have happened to that
man?
You know, they would have uh we would have got up and uh beat the guy
up.
We can't tolerate the smallest indiscretions in our communal space.
People are like very aggressively
protective. It doesn't mean that you're not har.
It doesn't mean you're not keen on goodness and wanting to see the best.
But the spirit has to be critical.
We spoke about this in the previous section on
on elen on gentleness and how gentleness cuts far more profoundly than
than than
uh than the sword.
So the prophetam is telling
us
bring ease do not bring
hardship inspire through glad tidings.
bring glad tidings.
Tell people about
the fact
that
as Allahh when he speaks about himself he says my mercy precedes my
wrath.
So in terms of a quotient in terms of like actual if we assess the volume
of discourse that is in in the realm of divine mercy versus the one that is
in the realm of divine wrath.
I think that the average discourse far outweighs wrath over mercy.
So there's faultiness in that.
Allah is saying my mercy precedes my wrath.
So and Allahh is telling us
about
I am as my servant assumes of
me.
If you assume of me good, I will be good.
If you assume of me bad, I will be bad.
Well, what knowledge or conception or spirit of God
of spiritedness around the sacred tradition do I possess that compels me to have a good
opinion of Allah, a a pleasing opinion of Allah?
The prophetam
says,
"None of you should
die.
None of you should pass until you have the best opinion of God."
So the when someone is
when someone is passing, they're on their deathbed.
The most important thing that you're talking to that person about in that moment is
what's your opinion of Allah?
Have the best opinion of Allah.
Allah is the most kind.
Allah is the most.
I was just someone that I loved recently who was passing away and it was her
last moments and I was kept on reminding her Allah is kind.
Allah is generous.
Allah is this.
And she say but I have sins.
I have so many sins.
I say well
he is this.
He's so beautiful.
He's so kind.
He's so gracious to you.
He gifted you this illness because he wants this that.
And you sit there because that's objectively the truth.
You know there's no what's the you're going to sit there and and the prophet says
none of you die
except that you have the best opinion of Allah.
Well, if I have a whole spirit and discourse around religion that is punishment center ccentric
and harsh and
uh
consequences, then what's going to be my opinion of
Allah?
And so we want to live in the beautiful balance.
Okay, should we
type? Let's jump quickly.
Yeah.
Sure.
So in that
absolutely I mean it's a it's a relevant introjection.
So I'll I'll take it.
May Allah bless you.
Uh
the what I actually told her, you know,
in that moment was
because Subhan Allah, so many of the people I love
who are I believe men and women of Allah, that's their ultimate concern before they're dying.
I have sins.
Is Allah going to be is going to Allah accept me?
And I tell these people
uh there was one there's a sister who's very near and dear to my heart and
you know she deep deep lover of Allah and the messenger.
She's still alive.
May Allahh be pleased with her
and a very elderly woman and she then she attended my series on
uh the afterlife.
I gave a series a few Ramadans ago on the afterlife and she she called me
frantically. She's like I had
I was so at ease.
I was so comfortable.
Now I listen to your afterlife series.
I'm terrified
now.
So I said to her, I said to her that all that has happened to your
heart is that balance has come.
Is that you have now a healthy heart.
A healthy heart
has
a lot of hope and a healthy dosage of fear.
A lot of hope.
The hope should
outdo the fear.
So hope
and then fear.
But those are the wings.
You can't have one without the other.
You can't have fear without hope.
You definitely cannot have fear without hope.
And you should absolutely not have hope without
fear.
So that is the spirit of it.
The spirit of it is
that
the the the critical quality that you direct towards yourself is
I need to make sure that I am never taking for granted the fact that I
am a sinner that I have making mistakes that I have fallen short and that I
need Allah to forgive me.
I need Allah to have mercy upon me.
Like you're saying like shifting or transitioning the nefs in that direction.
So you don't become apathetic towards sin or like whatever God's merciful I can do whatever.
No, you should have fear of Allah's punishment.
Absolutely. That's the only way.
You can't be a complete believer without that.
But the spirit that we're talking about in this particular regard is the notion of
that the the the the
envelope of the sacred tradition is an envelope of
not
because there is a discourse of religion that promotes a notion of harshness as if it
is a principle itself
like rigidity as a principle
um
exclusivity as a principle oneness as a principle like this is the only way, this is
the true way.
And then it's very harsh and blunt and aggressive and critical all the time.
And it's a lot of the a lot of the internet religion is like that.
You know, the internet religion that's a lot of that is completely antithetical to the prophetic
way.
I I I truly do not conceive of the prophetam endorsing any of that.
Even if some of the line items are technically true, but the spirit is so off
because the prophet told us about
the
where he
says
you will
in you will critique or or or or
criticize your prayer to their prayer.
You'll belittle your prayer to their prayer.
Meaning their prayer seemingly is better, but they are the dogs of
hellfire. Meaning what?
Meaning and he said he's like they're they're like an unrestricted arrow.
It just goes through, cuts everything, benefits no one.
Okay? What's the point if you're technically correct, but you've harmed everyone and everything in your
path? That's not the way of Satan Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
So he is saying your bath, your
purpose, give glad tidings.
Don't drive people away.
Someone who doesn't know anything about anything, who's so innocent, who's completely new, like I watch
this all the time and it pains me.
people who have no idea about religion, they're just kind of like
coming into the scope of Islam
and then they're met with a semi-truck, 18-wheel semi-truck just comes
and
Islam is this, you can't do this.
This is haram.
This is
guy, relax, relax, pump the bricks, pull over.
You know those like semi trucks that are pulled over on Route 80 who are sleeping,
they need to pull over and go to sleep with the other semi-truckss.
you're just coming in
and you're ramming people over
and and I'm telling you there's a lot of people
who enter into Islam
and then they're met with this semi-truck discourse of religion and then they just kind of
slowly wither away.
It's just because it's untenable to say I had no conception of religion.
I I love the idea of God.
Yeah. Yeah. You know, I believe in God.
Okay. Therefore, and then
they're like they're pummeled with all these come
relax.
You know, you once again it's not to say that we eliminate standards.
Of course, we have standards.
There is halal and haram.
Truthfully, there is.
There is right and wrong.
There is
and
disbelief. These things exist 100%.
We wouldn't be Muslim if we didn't believe in them as fault lines and boundaries.
But how did the prophet sallall alaihi wasallam present these truths to his companions is the
spirit that we're talking about.
Because when he says
he says listen it's like
if if if I were to tell
you
bring happiness to your
home.
What does that mean to you?
Okay, bring happiness.
Does that mean
let everything and anything and whatever happen at any time?
No. You're still going to have routines and disciplines and things have to be maintained and
the kids have to be put asleep at a certain time and blah.
There has to be order.
But what am I communicating to
you?
Step back. If there is no happiness in your home, then your home is not a
true home. Even if technically you may have things reg like you know like you have
your your your family like soldiers, right?
Just uh abiding by the routines, but you're not fulfilling the
spirit.
You're not fulfilling the spirit of it.
So this is what the spirit that prophetam is conveying to us and we see this
you know
um all throughout the
tradition is an essential part of
our
you know so the
just to give you some insights
the
they talk
about
if you look at the basic
obligations you see how
ease is embedded in each one of these obligations.
Salah for example, the man who came to the prophet wasallam and he he had uh
hemorrhoids really bad
hemorrhoids. So the prophet sallallaihi wasallam and the man could not get up like when he
would sit down and he be it would be very hard for him to get up.
So the prophet says if you cannot pray standing you pray sitting.
Then he says if you can't pray sitting pray on your side.
When there's people
uh in the hospital room and I see them as they're getting ill and I they
say, you know, I I I'm not able to
lift my back up.
Just motion with your head.
You can't motion with your head.
Just motion with your
eyes.
One of the principles of Islamic law
is
if things become constrained, the opinions become
uh opened or easy.
For example, someone has nothing to eat
except something that's haram.
You eat the haram.
No questions
asked.
This is
this is from the the the spirit of being embedded in
the
uh if you're fasting and you're sick, you break your fast.
There's you know there's no
there's no that should come from worship.
You shouldn't uh exhaust yourself into harm.
Prophetam says do not incur harm or not
inflict harm.
Do not cause harm.
Harm should not be facilitated.
So religion should not cause
That was a perfect example of the guy urinating in the
mas.
This is why uh this message is pretty strict about
and drinks.
Let's just continue inshallah.
What was I
saying?
Huh?
Yeah.
So, uh let's read the
next
excite my memory.
So the prophet sallall alaihi wasallam
says
that the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam according to our
mother
would the prophetam was never given a choice between two matters except that he chose the
easier of the two as long it was as long as it was not a sin.
So there's a very important that um people often
misunderstand which is
the the this hadith
of
that the prophetam was never given the choice of two things
except that he chose the easier of those two things.
The problem is the majority of people who use this hadith they stop
here.
They stop it right here.
They say well the prophet always chose that which is easier so religion is easy.
And so therefore always the easy route.
Now that is a very conditional conditioned statement because the prophetam
says
that as long as he does not
um
sorry
Muhammad
So he says sallallahu alaihi wasallam that the messenger of Allah wasallam was never given a
choice between two matters except that he chose the easier of the two as long as
it was not a
sin.
But if it was a sin
or if but if a sin isn't was involved he was the furthest of people from
it.
He was the furthest of people from sin sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
Nor did the messenger of Allah sallallahu alaihi wasallam ever avenge himself
sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
However, if that deemed sacred by Allah was violated, he would avenge
Allah the exalted
meaning to indicate a number of things that I hope we
extrapolate from this this hadith.
So first and foremost we're essentializing the idea of
of bringing
ease
and that when the
uh
many of the scholars of hadith when they talk about
what are the things that the prophetam is being made to choose from
they say that that is in reference to
the matters of Muhammad the matters of life dealings daily
dealings not
in matters necessarily of religion.
Why?
Because the idea here is that he says
um
the
as long as not sinful.
So there's no conception that in something in religion is sinful.
So because there's no conception that something in religion is sinful then therefore the the majority
of what is being spoken about in terms of this hadith are matters of daily dealings.
If this
circumstance is easier than that circumstance, we'll take this one as long as it's not
sinful.
That's one one very important uh
consideration for this hadith because people think that this auto this hadith automatically means that whatever
is
easier
in
religion superficially that that superficially by by that what I mean is that my subjectivity feels
that this is easier.
No, when it comes to
um
when it comes to
worship
and Allahh
he he he he gives us that which
is
that we are expected to fulfill the act of worship per perfectly as it is
uh conveyed to us.
So there's move away come this way.
Um
there is no conception where you say that for example
uh
that I I'm going to pray three times a day because it's easier and somehow that
becomes uh allowed.
Never
that you you're not going to conceive of yourself in the place of worship having choice
where you can manipulate and change because of what's easier more comfortable.
No, you when it comes to devotion, you see what does Allahh
want.
If it so happens to be that you're in front of two opinions and those two
opinions are genuinely legitimate opinions, then you and you then the the scholars
say
then you incline towards where your heart sincerely goes.
Meaning that if your heart based on two legitimate opinions that you have in front of
you, if your heart inclines towards one over the other and it's a sincere inclination, then
that's fine.
But what's important to understand is that you're never essentializing the nefs, the lower self, the
desires. That is never to be essentialized.
That
ease in religion is not what my nef inclines
towards
because the nef does not incline towards praying fud on time.
The nef does not incline towards that.
The nef does not incline towards
fasting. But so that is not to be conceived as hardship.
It's to be conceived as obedience.
And the the options and the choice
they happen mostly in worldly matters and sometimes in religious matters.
You understand what I'm talking about there?
So I don't want people what what the clearly indicate is that this is never a
um this hadith is not a lensure to
to just always find like people for example they do something very blameworthy called fatwa shopping
you know I'm looking for fatwa I'm looking for fatawa that are convenient to me so
I go shop for fatawa and I ask
if I don't like this one I'll go to that one if I don't get that
one I go to this one I go to that one and then suddenly the most
popular is the one who gives the easiest opinion all the time or the seemingly easiest
and then they'll and then people will think oh well prophetam he only chose the
easiest. No, you're you see how you're
you're actually you're actually playing a game here.
You're not being sincere and honest.
You're looking for the easiest.
is very different than the prophetam being
told
he was not given the choice of two things except that he chose the easier versus
different than I'm going to go and scour the earth looking for the easiest i.e e
that which is the most convenient for me.
That's not what the prophetam said to
do.
The language is critical.
This is the language should actually guide us.
So number one, he was not given a choice of two things.
Not that he was always out there looking for the easiest possible thing.
The second thing is that this was more in matters of worldly affairs, i.e.
matters of
than they were of matters of and devotion.
Although there is
there is choice in the matters of devotion but they're also
limited. Okay. You want to keep on cleaning.
Okay. Wants to she's going to take out all the coffee from the
from the floor
inshallah. Yes. Go ahead.
Yeah. Yeah.
I don't want to go into the subject matter but people
So is that a situation where I'm just going to take
I'm not going out and
I'm not going
these things are coming to me.
I've heard these
correct
listen so when it comes to fatawa
when it comes to
fatawa
I think the the the the appropriate way to approach a matter of fatwa is the
following. you truly find the credentialed qualified scholar or body of scholars not just any you
know person that you find on the internet you actually do your due diligence and we
spoke about this in Ramadan you do your due diligence you find someone that is
or a body that is objectively you know qualified body or represent of this particular subject
matter and not everyone's qualified to give fatawa in matters of finance
once you do that you present your fatwa
all right honestly and sincerely to seek the best opinion, not the easiest one, not the
one that's convenient, the best
one.
And then you present
and you may end up with two legitimate opinions, okay?
Two legitimate opinions that are standard and prevalent and out there.
401k is something like this.
Often there's 401k is just something that there are seemingly two very legitimate opinions that are
standard. I'm not going to get into details.
Don't ask me right now.
But whether you pay zakat
after excluding taxes and penalties and fees and then pay on the amount that is after
that or you treat it as money that you don't completely own and you wait until
you have complete ownership then when you bring it you pay on it and then you
pay thereafter whatever you take or if you have unmitigated
access
listen the my honest perspective on this is that it seems to be
that these are two legitimate opinions.
I tell
people
that's what because the prophet did give give
this
so when they say what does it mean
i.e. Take a dispensation from your heart.
Counsel your heart.
The prophet is saying that effectively if you have two legitimate
opinions, counsel your heart.
Take a dispensation from your heart.
What is your heart genuinely inclined towards
sincerely? If it's that one, go for it.
You have no
because these are two legitimate
opinions. So that's what that's what matters of you know that's how I'm saying in matters
of religion does happen.
you know um there is choice to be
made
and so you see I mean the prophetam gives us many examples
around
in this religion.
So he for example in the hadith
says
the easiest or the best of marriage is that which is done
with ease.
So
those who have the most baraka in their marriage are those who are easiest when it
comes to
their
their dowy.
Today people have taken dowry as like a representation of value.
Okay?
If we mean to you X, you will pay Y.
It's like if our daughter is of value to you, you will pay this amount.
That conception is a faulty conception.
This is not a matter of value,
right?
This is a this is a commitment.
It's a it's a commitment but it shouldn't be a barrier to
to to
entry
the way that it has become today.
You know we cannot we will not accept
uh less than based on some
uh
superficial social metric of what what should be and the numbers will just keep on
skyrocketing. If you're leaving it up to people's whims it's like up to 50 60k
in
a lot of these circles now.
The numbers just keep on going up.
What are we doing?
We're we've moved far away from
the prophetam is saying the best of marriages are those that are
easy.
So if you want baraka in your marriage, you want baraka in your uh you want
baraka in your life,
then make marriage easy.
I'm not once again, does that mean have no standards?
Does that mean accept anyone who walks through the door?
Does that mean do not do due diligence?
No, that doesn't mean any of that.
do due diligence, ask the right questions, be
thoughtful, but don't create barriers of hardship.
It's almost to like you're making someone jump through hurdles because I see this a lot.
I see people like wanting
the other to do a dance like, you know,
do a dance for me.
Jump through these hurdles.
Prove yourself that you are worthy.
Is that is that the right spirit?
Does that
uh bring about baraka?
No, doesn't bring about blessing.
So the proam
saying
the best of marriage that which is
easy.
You see what that means?
So when you put when you put barriers of entry around m you put barriers of
around in in terms of dowry you put barriers of entry in terms of the type
of wedding the
expectations these are
I have no doubt in my mind that a lot of the hardship that we see
in marriages today in the lack of baraka happens because the the barriers are so they're
so high the barriers to entry are so high you have to do a lot you
have to the expectations are
ridiculous you know I was in when I was in Egypt
um
driving with one of the Uber drivers And the guy's like 28,
29.
He's like, "Oh, alhamdulillah, I just got engaged."
I was like, "When are you going to get married?"
He
giggled. I said, "Why?"
He's like, "Uh,
I'm like 3 to 5 years away from marriage."
Said, "Why?" He's like, "Well,"
and he laundry list
he has to prepare this that, whatever, the apartment, the sheepka, the
the
He's like, "I'm minimum three to five years where I can save and even be in
a position to get I applied for the housing."
the housing, when am I going to get
up?
So there there's literally a marriage crisis, but still this really bad cultural habit of like
a laundry list of demands and expectations before you can come into the space of marriage.
There's going to be very little and very little baraka.
So if you want goodness in your marriage and there should be a principle before entering
into marriage and
inside of
marriage. If you want baraka and you want goodness in your marriage, make things easy.
Do not make things
hard.
And subh the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam when he was in his he made you know
prophet made one hajj.
Do you know what the most common thing that the prophet said in that hajj was?
It's a very beautiful uh no notion to consider the most the companion
said
what was
that?
Huh?
Your wife beat you to it.
Your
boy,
you got
him.
Do
without any
uh worry.
Do without any
concern. So the Sahab are saying the most common thing we heard the prophetam say during
Hajj
and Hajj is a place where it is like meticulous.
I mean subhah when I I've only made one Hajj alhamdulillah and if Allah wills I'll
make Hajj in a few weeks.
And
I was just, you know, you're there and then people from all AC anyone random
peopleum and they'll ask some technical I'm not they don't they have no idea I'm mash
but everyone's just asking everyone questions because there's a lot of details this that whatever like
when we're in Malifa
people were just like walking around are these rocks okay?
Is this size good?
Is this good?
And then you know like
everyone's and so there's so many technical details that you have to be mindful of.
And the fact that the most common thing on the tongue of the prophet wasallam
wasal
gives you an indication about the spirit that he he exuded sallallahu alaihi
wasallam. Uh the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
uh
he says
that
I stand for prayer.
This is not in the book by the way.
I stand for
prayer
and I want to lengthen my
prayer.
I hear the crying of the
child.
Then I I move quickly in my
prayer
because of my
dislike
to
uh bring hardship upon his mother.
So there is the gentleness that he has with children.
But you notice why did the prophetam highlight the mother here?
Because the young child is crying.
The young child crying you know the tears of a child
children are very forgetful.
They can go 0 to 60
shout and scream but then once they get their you know their
their mother soothes them by by by
nursing them or giving them whatever they immediately
quiet.
But the hardship on the mother is much greater.
H
what
the hardship on the mother is much greater
much greater because what
she
she's trying to pray.
She's trying to be devout.
She knows her child's there.
She doesn't want her child to be struggling.
She doesn't seeing her child stressed out is more stressful to her than anyone else.
Then she has to deal with the social pressure of everyone that's around listening and she
doesn't want to disturb the other people praying and she she has a thousand things that
are distressing her.
So the prophetam is saying that when I hear a child crying
for him sallallahu alaihi wasallam I move quicker in my prayer because I don't want to
bring hardship upon
his
mother.
This is his his empathy how plugged in he was or he is sallallahu alaihi wasallam
that's
why
was leading prayer and he prayed long you know he prayed for a very long period
of time
the prophet sallallaihi wasallam said to
him
oh
are you a man who makes or creates fitna
because he prayed
long
so then
he said to him
Three times he said
that
he said do you cause fa do you cause are you a man who causes so
much fna? So he castigated him.
So he
said
it would have been more appropriate you for you to pray
with
or
you know chapters from the shorter chapters from
this is during the time of the prophet
wasallam would it would have been more appropriate for you to lead with these
prayers. And he then he said to him
You have to understand that people praying behind you are who?
They are the
elderly. They are the the weak and those who have those who have
needs.
It's not physical need.
They they have needs like
they have things to get
to.
The
like so so okay the the elderly
is clear. Elderly be gentle on them.
kids, be gentle on them.
The weak, be gentle on them.
But
those who have needs, those who have deadlines, those who have things to get to, they
have urgent matters they have to tend to.
They have to move quicker.
They don't have the the quote unquote luxury of extending their prayer.
So you have to be mindful of all these categories of people.
What does that indicate to you about the
saiam?
Oh yeah. And then what I wanted to say was that in his personal prayer, prophetam
would pray at a length that was unparalleled.
And I spoke about this
you know the famous story of Abdullah praying with him and the prophetam he stood up.
He's like okay he was a young boy.
I'm going to pray next to the prophet.
Prophetam stood up
so
I couldn't I couldn't handle anymore.
But this was the prophetam praying by himself because the greatest joy for him sallall alaihi
wasallam was prayer
by far. This is where he found his joy in salah.
But when he was in the communal space,
gentleness and ease
was very pro prominent.
That's why when you think of the commun the spirit of the communal space, you have
to think about a spirit of
ease.
You know, do and and don't worry,
that does not mean we eliminate boundaries because the the the question
of
and I'll highlight this before Q&A and then we'll we'll take a few minute break.
The question of the question of choice
has nothing to do with
if
sinfulness. Why do I say this?
Because in the communal space it could it may have become that the bar the religiosity
bar has been
lowered
lowered so much so that the haram has become normalized.
That's a problem.
That's not ease.
That's blamew worthy.
We never normalize the haram or the sin ever.
Doesn't matter how much the community struggling to fulfill this or that obligation whether in terms
of
food or dress or conduct or finances.
Pick your pick your quote unquote poison as they say.
In everything there are there is a standard that has to be right here.
There's a lot of work happening here to clean this up before the
because if this gets caught, we're we may be exiled from triple IC
IC.
This is a good space.
We don't want to lose this
space.
Hassan, you may need to start the property hunt for our next location.
um
so I you know when we talk about a community of
ease
we don't talk about a community of lowering standards so that there is no more religious
standard there is no halal and haram
no
what that may mean I remember subhan allah I'll give you a very stark example of
this very stark when I was an imam in Boston
uh a young woman came into my office
drunk,
inebriated. I mean,
couldn't couldn't put a sentence together.
She was an exchange student
from a Middle Eastern
country. A very a very uh anyway, whatever.
Let's keep it
ambiguous. So, she they they knocked on my door.
My staff knocked on.
They're like, "She uh there's someone here."
She says she needs to talk to a sheh, but she's like I said, "Let her
in." And she was I said, "Okay."
She was so drunk there was no communication to be had that was
meaningful. Uh so I told them I said listen I told the sisters I was like
why don't you take her upstairs to uh and just take her to the sister's bathroom
and let her like freshen her up and then effectively lie her down in like the
one sister section just let her take a nap.
She just needs to
rest.
Few hours later she like woke up maybe 3 four hours later and then they
you know she had
you know kind of come back to her senses a little bit.
sat down with her
and I said to her, "What's going on?
What like what brought you here to the masjid?"
She said, "Um,
she said, you know, I left the club.
I was drinking.
I was partying.
I was like lost my mind.
And then
I felt really bad about myself.
So, I I looked up masid on Google.
I don't know why.
I just looked up masid.
And then this was the first one that came up.
I didn't even know this masjid
existed. And so, I just came.
I just I don't know.
I don't know why I'm here.
just I felt like I should come to a masid.
And anyway, long story short, you know,
she
uh
she was just saying how, you know, she came to the US and just rebelled, you
know, against everything that she knew from back home and her family and her life and
her culture and she had a really difficult opinion of her family and her culture and
blah blah blah, all religious culture stuff.
And so it was time, you know, for her to just live her life as she
wanted.
And you
know
everything about her life is haram.
This is a Muslim woman who everything about her day-to-day life is haram.
Her convictions are haram.
Her beliefs are haram.
Her practices are
haram.
But this is a person who's crying out for help.
This is a person who it was sent to you.
This is not someone who made the choice to come.
She was sent she was sent to the house of Allah by Allah.
There's no doubt of it.
Like I told the whole team I was like Allah sent her to the to this
masid. There's no doubt about it.
There's no, she didn't, you know, consciously say, you know what, maybe I should go visit
a masjid. She just something told her, go to a masid.
I don't know why, but just
go.
So the what then is your obligation as a community with someone like that?
You know, she everything I'm telling you when I say everything about her outwardly and in
her practice and her beliefs was haram, I mean it.
And I don't want to get into details but I think you can imagine.
Slowly but surely I told her I was like listen I invite you I have a
come to it Tuesdays
etc.
And she was like oh I don't know about that.
That's just like you know whatever.
I said you know whatever whatever makes sense to you.
You know here's so and so take some contacts and
and then like two weeks later I saw her in the back of one of the
classes like all the way in the back hiding behind a a pole.
you know, but there's all the way in the back hiding behind a P.
She's like looking this and then like just
slowly but surely she started coming closer and closer
and
I I I'll tell you it was one of the most profound stories of my life
seeing her transition and it was a it was a period it was a period of
time where we didn't nothing about the standards of Islam were changed.
At the end of the day she very much knows and haram she's not oblivious to
them. She's know she grew up as a Muslim.
She knows the
she violently knows them like they're like etched in her
brain.
But it was a matter of of of of
creating an ecosystem that made it where she slowly came to what is
good
because because of the ease with which she experienced this space and there was nothing harsh
about it.
And I'll tell you, I noticed in those years, there's a lot of Muslims that I
when I first dealt with them, they were very far away practicing.
But you don't when when when when you when you create an environment of ease that
is
principled, people naturally just their fra says I want to go to that.
When you don't create a fitna for them
by hitting them hard, by hitting them with that really judgmental look,
that judgmental tongue
that makes them re reject because okay, here is just another
X.
You know, sometimes you you guys know me, I don't pull
punches, but there's a difference between not being honest and sincere and
transparent. Every every circumstance has its language.
You have to be wise of what you
communicate. But you never judge you never a you never we don't judge people
aggressively like we are the standard bearers of truth and religion that we are the gatekeepers
that we are somehow Allah did not give me the responsibility of
being
you know are like the the police force of religion that's not
the
that's not what the prophet told us to do.
He didn't say you are
go out make sure you're holding a stick.
You see something wrong.
I'm telling you until today there's a religious discourse that exists that if I'm on the
first thing when I come down someone has to tell me what I've done wrong in
the
who taught you how to speak about religion this way.
Who taught you how to think about religion this way?
Did you actually hear what I was trying to say?
Why are you listening faultf finding?
No, I'm not saying we're all susceptible and need of guidance and correction.
And may Allah bless us with those who give us our gifts, which is corrections.
Allah Allah sends us those who will correct us.
But when your disposition as an average Muslim is to sit there and faultf find
and and and critically assess the integrity and the quality of the community and how bad
and fra and problematic and blamew worthy the community is and how irreligious and
that's your constant disposition.
Where did you get that from the spirit of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam? How do you glean that
from?
I can give you so many examples from the time of the prophetam where he did
things that you would like are you sure you're even the biggest of capital punishments.
People were coming to admit that they committed
zena.
And the prophetam would say things like, "You
sure?"
Well, maybe you did this.
Maybe you didn't
actually
cons.
That's a polite way to say, you know, you know what I mean?
The grown-ups know.
Maybe you didn't actually, you know,
make it in.
Perhaps it was just around.
Wai.
No. No. I'm pretty sure Allah said no perhaps you know even like even why because
the the the spirit of the prophetam is of course here's the thing if it's definitively
that the p that the mistake was made the punishment will be had it's no like
he he cannot negotiate religion the the command of Allah is the command of Allah
but he would do everything in his power to make and say hey no no no
you're fine you're fine you're fine okay no you're just you're mistaken no I'm pretty sure
you're so no no it could be it could be anything you
Why that spirit?
Why was he not a faultfinder?
And this is from his he was not a
faultfinder. He would he would lower his gaze to not see,
you know, he would push people away.
He say, "Go, go, go away.
Go away. Come back
famously. Go back and we'll talk after you give birth.
We'll see. We'll see."
She wanted to be punished.
He said, "No, no, we'll see.
Come back
later."
So I hope that spirit is clear and I hope it's clear that we're not talking
about
bending any rules or
lowering the bars or changing the religion.
The prophetam says the condition
is
the condition of ease is that as long as you're not committing a sin
that's the condition of ease
if that makes sense.
Let's take some Q&A and then we'll take a stretch break and we'll come back inshallah.
Yes,
brother. You're sitting on
the
come.
Yeah. Can I have
Yeah.
says
or
both
exist.
And so
he says do not stay away from the doubtful matters.
Staying away from doubtful matters is because you're
circling sin,
right? Just
like
just like the shepherd who's taking his flock around what you know the the peripheries the
peripheries where you may your your sheep may fall into uh
someone else's land and then they'll be taken from them or killed or something.
So there's a very big difference between
ease
and doubtful matters.
Yes, stay away from doubtful matters because that's a function of
sin.
That's a function of sin.
Once again, if the bound like the principle is
you choose ease as long as you're far away from sin,
but if this is a sinful matter
and
says this, it's a sinful matter or
it is
you know may take you to to sinfulness then you stay away from it
because then the question of ease is removed and what replaces it is
what
so ease is a function of
you know this is matter is is is
open
and the principle in matters is
so
most things are open
you know
you
well I was going to say what car to drive but then not today you know
who knows we shouldn't we got to be careful some car makers you
know
anyway
I hope you understand so
yes
just
what was
No.
Yeah.
So the the hadith where the
says
don't
don't be extreme so that Allah then makes your affairs one of extreme
or then Allahh makes your affairs
hard or harsh.
So don't be
um don't is don't be harsh
um and extreme in your disposition so that Allah then makes your affairs one of harshness.
This is
precisely for example like this example of salah
you know you you you set a standard that's very high
it may be a standard ofan and excellence for you it's a standard ofan it's not
a standard of Islam because in the grades of religion we have Islam which is the
lowest standard not not to say that in a bad way or a negative way but
just let's say it's standards Islam is here iman is here is here there may be
high levelan
like For example, if you put on yourself that you're going to do
uh
1,000
vikra day
and you make it as like a waj upon you and you're not necessarily qualified to
be there. It's just a you've made yourself a big ask or people who do ne
people who make and which is a blame worthy thing to do.
Near is when you make a promise to god for example ya Allah if you give
me this wahi I will fast this or I will give this much charity.
You should not do that.
That's not a praiseworthy thing.
um it's it's it's if you do it it holds
but it's blameworthy you should not do
that
Allah you say if ya Allah if you give me this I will fast 60 days
in a row ya Allah if you give me this I will donate
$100,000 and it's very difficult for you to fulfill so you
did
you
know
Allah made it difficult for you
Whereas you may be someone that in the realm of for you to do 10,000 salawat
a year a day
is
because that's your sunnah.
I know people like
this.
The prophet wasallam you know he he he encourages
um
continuity even if it's few in numbers.
So you have to you have to measure based on your capacity because one of the
big the reasons why a lot of people fail after Ramadan is they put a very
high standard of what they're going to continue to do and then they end up doing
nothing. So take it easy you know have a nice healthy standard for you where you
are at your level.
Same thing for our children.
You know sometimes people they push and drive their children in a way that's not natural.
It's unhealthy. It's unnatural to
expect of them.
I'm not saying don't push your children, don't challenge them, but do it in a measured
way that's healthy and balanced.
Give them time for comfort and ease and and and happiness and joy and then for
discipline and work and and and
uh and devotion.
Do both.
Um my my nephews they live in Turkey and the the masjid right next to them
the imam you know as soon as salah is over
you know they're he's he's playing with them in the mah
immediately you know every they my brother was telling me they were he was like all
Ramadan they were like driving me insane wanting to go
prayaw
but we have to go pray why because of the imam who just you know he
brought them in in a way where they experienced the beauty of both
worlds
this is the spirit of
Adam.
Yes.
How
about
you?
Everything has to be there's there's a calculus for everything you do in that regard.
So the how you're going to negotiate for example like the story I
gave
and
the idea of of of
not uh removing standards like at the end of the day you know you open up
a door
and you say you're welcome to come
you know but for like for example there was someone I remember distinctly who would come
and the dress the the the style of dress was too much too revealing and it
was
problematic you know in a way that many people were just it was causing actually a
social like
so
okay please make sure that you're you're there's a certain basic standard of dress that's maintained
because it should not be that revealing right so you're you're you once again you don't
have to make it
where you don't tell this person
anything no you can lovingly and graciously and kindly say
please you're welcome to come but here are the basic standards that need to be you
know
appre
appreciated which which is which is you know for example in this woman's state that I
mentioned no I mean I knew and my core team knew that she was inebriated it's
not as if I normalized drunkenness in the masid like I knew my core team knew
but no one else knew yeah if if if she came to the masjid holding a
coor's light I'd be like
you know please you cannot do that that's haram that's not allowed you're not going to
say
come with your alcohol and drink openly in the masjid, you're not going to you're not
going to
uh
encourage that or welcome that.
You understand what I'm saying?
So those are the standards that you maintain that don't compromise the integrity of the status
quo.
Um but and and I would I just want to also articulate that this the culture
of
ease
is actually more of a spirit
than it is a
um like a judicial
standard. Meaning
that
one of the problems that I see often in massagid is that people the way they
function in masjid space is like rules and regulations than a spirit of welcomeness, spirit of
ease.
I'm all about rules and regulations by the way.
I'm stickler for them.
However, what's the spirit?
Because the prophet wasallam was a man of
a man of beauty, a man of excellence, a man that was welcoming and inviting and
very and and people even those who made the most egregious mistakes found their comfort in
his
company. But he showed them, he told them what the rules were.
He guided them to them
versus that the entry point into the Muslim communal space are rules and regulations.
That's the big distinction.
Like is the entry point rules and regulations like bluntness?
That's what I'm talking about.
Like we've we've turned the religion into the purest representation of like
legalities. Where is im andan?
Where is our connection to God, our belief in God?
Where is the beauty of the divine?
Where is beauty?
Where is excellence?
Where is the connection?
Where is good character?
You know, we're always complaining in massagid of, you know, I'll be honest, my own children
will go to certain massagid and the first complaints that they have is like, well, that
person yelled at us for this and this person yelled at us for that and I
can't stand that.
Oh, where is the where is this event or this activity this time?
Oh, it's here.
Ah, I don't want to go because there's someone there is always like,
you know, jump down our throats.
Okay, what what are we doing?
What's the point of like I'm not saying we shouldn't strategize around maintaining the integrity of
the space and having basic rules and regulations
100%.
But when the spirit and the and the relationship that people have to the
space
is like a disciplinarian with a stick
that was not the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
So I when we talk about
the
a space of ease, we're talking about a
spirit.
I hope that's clear.
May Allah guide us to what's best and forgive us if we're saying anything wrong.
Yes.
Yeah,
very good.
So the hadith around the salah children 710.
First off,
I just want to be clear something we have to change in our discourse around the
word daraba. Daba does not mean beat at all.
Okay? At all.
I'm saying that, you know, very lovingly, not aggressively.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
No, no. I'm saying like because I hear this all the time.
Islam says you can beat women, you can beat.
No, no, it does not.
There's no
The prophet never said, the Quran never said beat
because beat has a very beat is like beat up like I'm going to knock you
out, teeth out, bruises.
But we don't beat
the pro. There's no beating in Islam.
Okay.
The word da is a very different word.
The word dabba is a very different one.
So just just like off the bat.
The second thing is
the
idea
that the prophet sallallaihi wasallam
is
teaching parents that you now have an obligation to teach your children that as they are
coming of age
here is the transitional period.
So you're at the age of seven introducing them to salah.
Meaning what?
Come to pray.
You have to pray.
Before seven, it's play, it's fun.
They come, they want to ride, they want to jump all around, they want to whatever
they want to, you know, flow in around you like kittens.
That's fine. They can come, leave, whatever they want.
Seven, you're starting to say, "No, come pray.
Come." Now, I'm starting to like proactively ask you to come stand with me.
Stand with us.
Ya Allah, go grab your hijab.
Go do this.
Sit down. Here's your little musah.
Yah. All the kids, everyone get your mahalah.
It's time to pray.
We have a culture, a standard that we're encouraging proactively.
Yall, you have to come and pray.
You're using the word have
to,
but you're using it, you
know,
with some leeway,
you know, meaning that if you're gonna
let a fed pass because you just feel like it's
they're dead, they're exhausted, they can't function, you know what I mean?
I just can't get them up.
We can let we'll let them when they wake up, they can pray.
7 to 10, you do that.
Now 10 comes the prophet Muhammad sai wasallam is saying
now
now the principle of praying five times a day the devot the act of devotion has
to become
essentialized
meaning
the way we
uh
talk to our children well before the age of 10 around getting up for school there's
no
negotiation like we don't have that type of uh
sympathy and mercy.
You're going to school.
Okay? And we will even say even if you're dying, you're going to
school,
right? I don't care.
I don't want to.
I'm tired. Get up.
You're going to school.
Why? Because we have a certain idea around schooling.
That means
I cannot squander this.
I You have to go to school.
All that is when we communally talk about that.
All we're saying is
there is a standard.
You're going to be disciplined.
You're going to fulfill this standard.
There's an obligation.
That means going to school.
you're going to go to school.
Correct? Same thing with bedtimes.
Same thing with sleep routines.
Same thing with showers.
I don't want to shower.
You're going to shower.
You will grab that child and toss them into the
tub.
On principle, there's an act of devotion called taking a shower.
You're going to do
it.
Are you going to negotiate with them on it?
No, you're not.
same thing age of 10
treated the way you treat all these other things that we have no problem with that's
how you treat prayer
that's how you understand the hadith
meaning it's there's disciplinary measures if you're not
doing
okay
and the word is not that you're going to
it's like okay you're not going to pray and you put on your boxing gloves no
that's not the
means you're going to be disciplined that means you're going to be you know and and
and and listen, we can open up a whole discussion around, you know, spanking and not
spanking and whatever and whatever.
And it's a whole like
discussion culturally, socially, whatever about
but there's appropriate, you know, physical, you know, that's that's that's not be, you know, um
like an
not animalistic, not whatever, but it's
okay. You have to get an order.
Don't do that.
Your child hits your their sibling, you may don't do that.
Don't you do this, right?
You do this to your child.
Do not hit your child.
Do not hit your brother.
Don't hit your sister.
Okay.
Did you just beat them?
No. You discipline them very gently, very clearly like you you opened up their idea, their
system to something.
That's in the similar vein.
Allah
the brothers have not asked a question.
We'll come back to this.
Any
brothers? Got
we got too many sist
no brothers. We got the front line of sisters.
The
front line of front line of defense.
No I I it's it's not beat.
No, there is there is
so dabba daraba can
loosely
be translated in the Quranic and prophetic sense as
a gentle hit.
But even the word hit itself I don't think conotes the proper connotation of how the
prophet used
it.
What's the best
translation? Yeah, it's actually closer to a physical tap.
Physical. It's physical.
Yeah,
it's definitely physical.
Yes.
Yeah. But by the way, when the prophet wasallam
says
it doesn't mean
it doesn't mean that the standard issue is that you have to.
No, he's not saying that.
He's saying that there's it's disciplinary measures.
And he's also implicitly indicating that a part of the repertoire of disciplinary measures would be
that you ultimately have to engage in
some sort of physical touch, physical tap, physical indication of of discipline that may come to
a point of
of possibility. So it's almost as if like listen if you're going to have to
you may have to do this.
You may have to resort to this.
It's a
whether it's last or not.
I'm not going to make a but it's a you may it's like you know it's
it's so significant that they pray you're going to have to resort potentially to this
just like for example if your child who is like being
aggressive towards another child you may have to physically intervene and grab them say hey you
I told you three times do not touch your sibling and so you grab their hand
maybe you squeeze their hand maybe you tap their hand you know that's you're you're going
to have to resort to that
Yes.
So I think that this once again that's a very good question the spirit spirit that
you cultivate. The spirit that is cultivated
um
in the religious in the space of family around religion is first off it is a
spirit. So it's who you are.
It's how you think, how you feel, what you communicate, how you express.
And that the overwhelming dominant narrative has to be beautiful.
All of our children should grow up and they should live in a world where Islam
is a very beautiful
experience. It's a beautiful experience with with u with how you get together as a community
in celebration in joy in dua
and
uh
nasheed
like they experience the joyous
beautiful happy
reality of Islam which is what Islam is.
So you have to create an ecosystem where that is the case where their experience with
religion is overwhelmingly beautiful.
That's
why
play make
life with regards to Islam and their whole existence of
of
it's joy it's happiness it's play
make it playful
make it fun make it
beautiful but then we are starting to transition into adulthood right what's the process of transition
there's no doubt that you and I know that for them to start to transition they're
going to have to start being more disciplined
transitioning kids from a place of like
uh endless glee into now, okay, you're going to have to start put
restrictions, you know, it's not always now about just playing all the time.
Now, you have to sit down and be a bit more quiet.
You have to be more respectful, right?
Yeah. When when when there's a toddler, you know, wobbling around, you're not going to, you
know, expect of them certain things, but as the child grows, you start to
expect.
So I I think if you theorize it
around the expectations that you have for your child to have a proper now growth into
adulthood and you have expectations of their speech, their character, you're not going to allow that
your 11 or 12year-old is disres is is speaking disrespectfully to an elder in the community
or to a one of your friends.
They come in and they're disrespectful or they're condescending or they're dismissive.
You're not going to accept that.
So you're going to hold them accountable.
There's going to be disciplinary measures.
You never talk to an elder that way.
If you do this, whatever.
If you disrespect me, you will be punished this way.
If you don't listen to what I'm telling you, I'm going to take away your screens.
So, there are natural disciplinary measures that we engage in to ensure that the child is
transitioning from childhood to
adulthood. The same exact logic that you apply to all the standard things that we know
in life, you apply to religion.
It's the same exact logic.
There's nothing really that different about it.
And do not allow people to pigeon hole you
to say well like you know look at what you religionist do you're making your you
know child we make our children look at these like
people who are in extracurricular inter mural sports they treat it like they're in the
military you know they're dragging these kids around
dressing them up like I don't know what and putting them in and they're like they
can barely talk and they're you know have the most rigorous training and whatever and socially
everyone's celebrating that nonsense.
I'm not I'm not saying interal sports are bad, but you know what I'm talking about.
There's a lot of this stuff is just crazy.
People are crazy.
They lose their
mind.
But there's no
people have no problem with this stuff.
Like it's just so socially normal.
But somehow when it comes to religion, so why is the child implicitly like okay or
learning that this is good and because they're getting a lot of social
validation. When you get a lot of social validation and then you get pray oh okay.
So all this hard work and discipline is paying off
because I won a trophy.
I got a
prize.
So you know what you could do is you could ensure that in those stages of
development and growth that they are incentivized that they are getting celebrated and they are getting
prizes.
It's a very joyous thing.
One of the things that my father instituted in our family
was
you know a little mini ba but in the good sense not in the bad sense.
no one lose their
mind.
Meaning that for example, he would we had salah
would mean
that
when it's seven, you have a big party.
So my kids, they inherited the same thing.
Khadijah is going to turn seven in September, inshallah.
She's counting the days for her salah party.
Literally, it's a party for
Eidh for Salah.
It's a Eid for Salah.
It's a it's a party for salah, for prayer.
Seven and 10.
Big part big deal in our c the culture of our home.
Why? because salah is coming and
you know now you're going to and my father always gives this like big
you know talk and and like it's like really the whole family comes together to usher
in for this young member of the family that they're coming into the space of salah
now
when we come together you have to stand up you have to pray in a particular
way you create pageantry around you celebration you create a spirit
and then yeah like you marker like year one year two until they grow and you
you create an environment about it.
But the problem is
uh
hold on hold
on.
I'm so
huh
Melissa that's what I was going for.
I was look I was right there.
I was right there in my uh
top five or maybe top
the
uh
Muhammad. But you see like we can we can we have the ability
to create an attitude, a spirit, a culture around something that even when you do have
to discipline, it's not the end of the world.
The problem is, and this is why people have a knee-jerk reaction to any type of
discipline when it comes to religion, because the standard method of discipline is just one.
It's just like, you know, they say a surgeon only knows how to cut and a
carpenter only knows how to use a hammer.
We have that problem in religion now.
We think that the only way is
is the hammer or the or the the
scalpel. That's our problem.
So that's why we have this like aversion to discipline in religion.
But that's not because there should no discipline is an essential part of life.
We can't exist without discipline.
We can't exist without consequences.
Our children will never grow if they don't have that.
You know that full well.
There's no such thing as a child growing in any capacity of life without there being
consequences and and
um expectations and punishments.
We know that.
So religion does not operate outside the norm.
It's just the style, the approach, the system, the spirit.
You've given choices, you've given chances, you've given this, you've given that.
You've inspired. You told this.
Listen, at the end of the day, Habibi, now you have to do what I'm telling
you. I've told you once, twice this.
I've told you this way, that way, this way.
There's no choice now.
Get up and pray.
Get up and do this.
Go to bed.
Whatever the case
is.
Let's I wanted to uh I was hoping to be a little bit further along at
this point, but you know, I have a problem and you guys can clearly
tell,
do you have any questions?
Are you committed to never asking a question again?
No.
You only seek your guidance from God now.
man, you know, he asked one question innocently a few weeks back and then
it wasn't there's no bad questions they say.
I mean, I disagree with that
statement. Let's wrap this hadith up and then
transition.
Um,
he then says sallallahu alaihi wasallam after
So we spoke about that that which is not a sinful act.
He
says
he said if it was a sinful matter the prophet wasallam would be the furthest away
from it.
So if there is any inclination towards sin or indication of sin
even close the prophet would be the furthest away from that matter.
So as just a you know a philosophical underpinning and going back to the questioner who
said about the Muhammad when you asked about the hadith
of
the
discourse of ease in religion has nothing to do with being close to sin.
I just want you to put that as a principle in your mind.
Ease is not you can be right on the precipice of wrong
and you're fine.
That's not what we're talking about.
Like I gave you guys this example of uh someone who heard the hadith
of the God's curse is upon those
who
those who pluck
their eyebrows, the one who doesn't and the one who has it done.
And so the person said, "Oh, so it's just God's curse."
Like it's not
haram.
I was like, "Oh, I think God's curse is enough
to like compel you to stay away from something, right?
Meaning
that
because the idea that people have well like you know the religion is easy don't make
it
hard
the religion is easy don't make it hard
meaning what you want me to say that which is
haram is halal
or that which is blameworthy is not blamew worthy that is a lensure that we do
not have the haram will always be haram
no questions asked the blameworthy will always be blamew worthy no questions asked
how we then communally or familiarly negotiate someone who is struggling with their uh this part
of their devotion or that part or they're a little bit weaker here or there.
We've spoken about this.
That's a very different story.
We can work with people as they're growing in their commitment.
They're trying to be better in all of the matters of religion, but we don't we
don't ever blur the
lines.
Is that clear?
So when it comes to our communal religious
discourse the halal and the haram have to be very clear
a very apparent how we can work ourselves up to it that's a different story inshallah
so I just don't want anyone to assume that
ease
because a lot of people say you know they say it's like the religion is easy
all right so relax don't take it so seriously God doesn't care
about what you know a few hairs
no
you don't tell God what he cares about.
He God tells you what he cares about.
You don't tell him.
You don't you don't assume or project that God cares or doesn't care.
God doesn't care about a beard.
Relax. It's not a big deal.
That that's not your, you know, that's called your that's called relativism.
That's called, you know, subjectivism.
My subjectivity makes me think and feel that this is not a big deal.
Right? Because what?
Religion is easy.
That's that's all nons.
This is all where we're talking about when any discourse of religion and ease
that allows you for you to facilitate sin
or that which is sinful is a nonsensical discourse in
religion. I hope what I'm saying is clear because I'm trying to identify the faulty usages
of ease in religion that people talk about all the time which is somehow an elimination
of standards and boundaries and halal and haram.
So the prophet wasallam
said
so here he then says that there was no matter
um that he he would never uh avenge himself sallallahu alaihi wasallam never would he avenge
himself for himself.
self
and this is also an indication of the of
the ease
of
that a part of his spirit of facilitating a culture of ease is that you could
get away
with
a direct you know infraction against him.
He would not
lie.
And this shows you some of the truly profound qualities of our
because
imagine
if those who wronged him,
he held them accountable for it.
He would have created
a barrier to entry that was profound because a lot of people they had adverse reactions
to what he was telling them.
So if each time those who
accosted him or insulted him or cursed him or mocked him, if he if he took
them to count or he avenged for himself, what do you think that would have meant
for terms of God's
revelation? So he would only
avenge
when they went against God.
That's the only time I'm going to draw a
line.
Meaning there's a few depths to this and please pay attention because it's very important.
Number one,
the prophetam was more keen about God than
himself. Insult me, mock me, uh aggress against me, I'll tolerate it.
I'll deal with it.
I'm not going to avenge
myself
now.
But God red line, no questions asked.
That's where that's where we
start to like we go toe-to-toe now.
So number one that makes sure that
the the people have a space to actually walk in
you know because if if if the boundary was shut off around the prophetam in himself
for himself I'm not saying now for us it's different but the prophet for himself no
he was saying I'm going to open up the door so you can get to
god
and two it indicates that he never cared about himself for the sake of himself it
was always about for the sake of Allah subhana wa ta'ala
for us the standards are the prophet sallallaihi wasallam is a part of the sacred boundary
that is not to be touched and that is by the divine command so we are
not ever in a position to say well the prophet did
not
for his own sake ever seek avenges so then we can let people no no no
no no no no the prophet is
as they say is a red line
because the boundary that we're talking about of entry point is Allah
for us
the prophet for his own self
saying
I will give this a pass that's just his right to do for himself sallallahu alaihi
wasallam but not ours to on his behalf is this
clear
but I just want to highlight how that that that the fact that he never took
because that was so
contrary to the status quo in that age or in any age for that matter where
else do you have rulers
and power players, sultans,
presidents,
kings,
you know, Caesars who would ever allow for their own person to be
insulted or but the prophetam clearly did not exist for himself.
The mission was for the sake of Allahh.
So when we protect the honor of the prophet wasallam and by that I mean that
we defend his honor
we do it because of the integrity of the sacred tradition of
Muhammad. And there's so much more to say but we should move a little quicker than
I
am.
Uh
alaihi
wasallam. The prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam said, "Shall I not inform you of whom
is denied the fire or of whom the fire is denied?"
The fire is denied
every approachable, amicable, easygoing
person.
So the frier is prohibited upon anyone
who is approachable, who is amicable and
easygoing as in accordance with what the prophet wasallam is telling us.
So as a standard spirit and disposition that you should have in your own person
is that you are hyen
means that I can actually come and talk with you that you're approachable that there's no
ridiculous barriers to entry to even have to interface with you.
A lot of people they are not
it's heavy. It's they're heavy.
Their presence is heavy.
They're very inaccessible.
Uh you just you don't even know how to begin.
You sit there strateg I have people come to me to sit there strategizing about their
about going to approach a loved one about a topic they have
should I don't even know how to begin to like how should I approach them I
have this big issue I have to talk to them about that person's not
hanging
you mama came mama's there in the back
take the cookies to
her
love you
best.
Um,
so
is
approachable
Muhammad. Lean means as the translator says it
amicable. No, wait.
Did he say
amicable? He said amicable.
Yeah.
So
amicability
is
is is is like
agreeableness that you can you can have a healthy communication with this person.
They're agreeable. They're amicable.
They're not they don't stunt you in their
discourse. And so you know there's one thing that I don't even know how to approach
a person.
The other very difficult thing is that it's impossible to have a conversation with you
because it's just it's like a minefield.
you step the wrong way, you're going to get yelled at, attacked.
They're gonna if you if you say the wrong thing, someone's going to be so injured
and harmed and offended and bothered and
no. So there there there has to be
there has to be an amicability and agreeableness in
in speech that you're able you're someone that's easy to talk to.
So there's you're easily approachable and that you're easily
uh you're easy to talk
to
and you're
easygoing. Easygoing is you know you know who easygoing people are in society?
Those were
overlooked because
overlooked, you know, because if you look at the average
family,
it's like you'll see the person in the family who's the harshest, the most aggressive, the
one who can have a really visceral reaction, they get all the attention.
Because
people,
you know, if you if you cross them the wrong way, if you don't give them
enough attention, if you don't give them enough praise, they're going to get so offended and
harmed and hurt.
So, it ends up being that some of the most
difficult members of the family or difficult members of a space.
They get the most attention.
They get they get the most acknowledgement.
They get the most praise.
The
calculus is made more for them.
But if you're an easygoing
person,
just you pass by like, you know, a ship in the sea at night, no one
care, you you'll receive very little praise, very little acknowledgement, right?
People are not factoring for you the way they factor for
others.
Why? Because you're the easygoing one.
So sometimes people who are easygoing, they get really like messed up about this.
like how come so and so gets this attention that attention this acknowledgement this praise this
that whatever it's because it could be very well I'm not saying every all acknowledgement or
praises just because that person is difficult but often what I've seen in social calculus is
that it's
at the end of the day if I don't factor you in a particular way I
know you're going to I'm going to get an adverse reaction from you if I don't
acknowledge you a certain way I know I'm going to hear lip I know if I
don't praise you in a certain way I have this so I'm only factoring I'm like
an overdrive thinking well I need to make sure that 1 2 3 4 don't get
offended don't get bothered don't get hurt don't this so who's going to fall through the
cracks the easygoing
person
is that clear
so the fact that the prophet is saying that fire will not touch
those who are
approachable those who are you know easy to talk to and those who are
easygoing so you're just like water under the bridge that's your existence be that imagine if
humanity was full of people like
What a beautiful way to be.
May Allah make us from these people who have you know beautiful character and the
prophetam tells us in
Allah
the
believer who is
easygoing be easygoing person
and I'm telling you you may not necessarily get all of the admiration and praise and
you may not be because unfortunately in our culture
you know
if it bleeds it leads
unfortunately you It does.
People People don't care about status quo.
People don't care about like easygoing times.
People care about like
chaos and pain and suffering and
accidents and
that get that's what gets garners the most attention.
But it's not about attention.
It's about having a good life.
If you're easygoing person, you'll have a very good life.
You'll know how to be happy daytoday.
You'll know how to be very happy if you're easygoing because Allah loves the easygoing believer.
So be
easygoing, you know, everyone should learn this.
Be easygoing with your husband.
Be easygoing with your wife.
Don't have like don't always be, you know,
um, charged up
and like you just, you know, you're like a pressure cooker.
Just always uptight.
The proam does not, Allah does not like uptight
people.
And sometimes people, they have this idea that
they're uptight for the truth.
You know, there's this category of people.
They're really uptight.
They're really aggressive, but it's the truth.
You know, it's virtue.
It's
this.
I'm not sure
how
on like I don't know how sincere that is.
There seems to be something more about your emotional disposition, your psychological disposition than your commitment
to truth as it is.
Because the prophetam was there was no one who was more committed to the truth.
But he was never uptight.
Why was he not uptight?
Did anyone commit himself to the truth more than the prophet sallall alaihi wasallam?
No. But he was not an uptight person.
He wasn't an aggressive harsh person.
So if you have a religious discourse that makes you
uptight
and aggressive and people are terrified to make a m mistake in front of you and
the only reason they factor you in because they're worried about what you're going to say
about them and that and you know the list goes on.
We all know this stuff.
You have a flawed conception of
religion. Is this message clear?
I hope it
isn't.
Was there a hand up?
Okay.
Um,
so that fire
you know is prohibited upon everyone who is approachable, easy, close.
Satan
Muhammad he translates kharib as
folksy
interesting translation the fire is but denied um every approachable amicable folksy easygoing
person
here and I think what what what is I mean folksy is an interesting translation but
kharib literally means that they are
um
recognizable meaning that you are someone who
your presence is comforting.
Your your presence is
uh
you're not like an
aberration. So your your your presence is a is is
uh
is comforting that you when you're around
you you just feel like you know alhamdulillah this person's around
you know because the way they are it's not they're not sticking out like a sore
thumb. They don't make you feel a certain way.
They're not aggressive in a particular way.
They're not opinionated in a particular way.
Folksy is a nice fun translation of the word
khib.
Um
and because we we we like familiarity.
We like what we know like we like
and the prophetam was very familiar to people.
Although he had
he had strong different opin like beliefs that were in contradistinction to the status quo but
he never felt
alien.
He never felt alien.
He always felt
close
and and uh and accessible sallallahu alaihi
wasallam. Um
Allah so beautiful mashallah.
So he says so reflect oh Muslim on these prophetic statements that combine all pure character
traits. Reflect oh Muslim upon these prophetic statements.
This is what Abdah
now is saying.
Look at all these prophetic statements that combine all pure character traits and illuminous marinis
mannerisms. The messenger of Allah sallallahu alaihi wasallam detailed them in order that his ummah
might realize them
for they are part of the religion and have an enormous impact upon faith and a
great standing in the scale.
Indeed they are part of faith
not gratuitous nicities.
It's not just a matter of
like it's not just about being
nice
and like being socially agreeable.
It's a matter of faith.
So
is highlighting that
being
having
all of these qualities this is a matter of faith.
It's a matter of devotion.
And so, you know, once again, if you do not have
a language of gentleness, a language of accessibility and agreeableness, if you don't have this,
then there's a faultiness in your faith, in your conception of
belief.
All right? And so beware of the reality of theite.
Beware the reality of the kharite.
The one
who
is committed to such a
wrote superficial conception of the legal
tradition even of the theological one.
But they are like
a a painful harmful arrow that just flows through the community cuts everything in its path
and benefits no one.
As the prophetam said, may Allah help us to grant us the best of
character. The next section is his directives regarding disseminating greetings of peace.
His clarifying greetings of peace are rights of Muslims and their many religious merits and great
impact. So this is on
the merits
of
he says the first
virtue
that the first right the first virtue that we're going to he's going to reflect on
is that the idea of sending salam
is from the rights of a Muslim over a Muslim.
So it is said uh the narration of uh
in that is found in Muslim on the authority
of
that there are six rights of a Muslim over a Muslim.
Six.
It was asked what are they oh messenger of Allah?
He said when you meet him
greet him with salam with peace.
When he invites you, accept.
When he seeks your counsel, be sincere.
When he
sneezes
and says, "Alhamdulillah, respond
with
when he falls ill, visit him.
When he dies,
attend his janaza."
So
please,
all six of these rights, they should be imprinted upon our minds.
What are these six rights?
Let's repeat them together so that we never forget them.
The first right of the Muslim over the Muslim
is
that if he meets you, greet him with
peace.
This is from the h the right of the Muslim.
It's not a nicity.
It's not you being gracious.
It's not you being a respectful uh you know young boy or girl.
No, this is a right.
Rights are very different.
meaning you don't
have
the right not to fulfill a right.
It's a duty and obligation.
This is how
critical it is to say
in the communal space.
You're bothered with someone.
You're frustrated. You don't have the right to not say salam.
You don't because it's the your brother or your sister's right to say salamlaykum to them.
I'm not in a mood doesn't mean you don't say salamkum.
Hey, why didn't you say salam?
I
Definitely not. Why?
I'm just I don't want
that's not a that's not that's not an excuse.
That's not a reason,
right? That's not an intelligible reason not to say
salam.
You see a brother, you see a sister, you say
salamkum, even if you can't stand their guts.
Alaykum. So the first isalam
alaykum.
The second is when you are invited you accept
either.
Of course there's some conditions in this.
It's not every single invitation all the time that you have to accept.
If you don't then you know you're somehow not fulfilling someone rights.
But as a basic standard if you are invited you accept an invitation as a basic
standard. But to get into the details of this will really distract us.
So I don't want to get too far down the rabbit hole here.
When someone seeks your
advice you give it to them.
And I think this is a very
huge
squandered right in the communal space.
We do not give to each other.
I've said this many times and I'll continue to say it.
We are
not fulfilling our rights to each other
when we lack advice giving.
We have to be giving
a lot more sincere, honest, thoughtful, kind, generous advice because it's a right that you and
I have. And by the way, rights are things that can be taken on the day
of judgment. That's something to think about.
Rights are something that on the day of judgment, I can come to you and say,
"You did not give me my right.
Well, I want it now.
I want to make up for it
today.
All those years you knew and you didn't tell me.
Okay, now I want I want it made up for me
today.
May Allah protect
us."
When he sees, you say, "Alhamdulillah."
When someone seizes their right is that you respond by saying by by they say alhamdulillah
and you but you say you respond by
saying
the says that the first one
to
say alhamdulillah
was
and the first one to say
Allah
because the
narration indicates that or the report indicates that sa Adam when he was fashioned he was
fashioned first as clay
and he was this large 60 cubit
you know structure or being
and the
angels would flow through Adam when he was still in clay form
until Allahh
breathed the soul into Adam then Adam the first thing that he did was sneeze when
the
soul was breathed into him
and so when he sneezed
he naturally said alhamdulillah praise be to Allah
and so that's the first thing that sa Adam uttered Alhamdulillah.
And then Allahh responded to Adam by telling
him.
So praise be to Allah.
And the response was may God's mercy be upon you.
So the first one to say alhamdulillah was Adam.
The first one to say
was Allah subhana tala.
And so this is a right.
This is a right.
And now
I mean I the implications of these rights being fulfilled are truly profound.
Each one of them.
The right of salam if it was fulfilled has a powerful social implication.
Very powerful. What it cultivates in terms of spirits and moods and relationships and warmth and
love and care speak endlessly.
That has very powerful implications.
The implication of a community of believers that when such an innocuous act like a sneeze
results
in
an exchange that is so sacred, so beautiful.
Alhamdulillah.
you know you because it's it's an
inadvertent act
you know you you can't control it comes comes comes
and so there is
when they you know quote unquote muse around the subtleties here they'll say that you are
praising why are you praising
Allah
because in the same vein of
s Ibraim
um sa Adam when he sneezed
it was inadvertent it was something that
just
you know he had no control over and so you You know, the the the notion
here is
that
the spirit of praise of God is one that permeates all of your states,
advertent or inadvertent.
Whether you're thoughtful, conscious, mindful, you wished it, willed it, wanted it.
When you sneeze, do you want it?
I mean, sometimes you do want, you're like, I need to get this one out.
But it's still even the feeling to want to sneeze is something that's being impressed upon
you. So, the fact that your expressiveness is, oh, praise be to Allah.
Alhamdulillah.
So it's a it's an expression of
surrender even if when you force me to sneeze.
Alhamdulillah that's the
attitude. It's a very
beautiful
consideration and but that does not go unnoticed.
So then the mercy of a god is exacted
upon
you know so the community of believers who are surrounding this
person
you know of course now technically speaking they'll say that
to
say
it's a communal obligation.
So
so if one person says
it suffices everyone but you should compete
you know there should be a symphony of
try to get into that of course that person who said
suffice for the rest of the because by the way the interesting thing is you
sneeze
and everyone stays silent we're all held accountable we all
squandered this brother's right or that sister's right
so if one of us says
then it suffices for the group
but you should compete
should compete. You want to be a part of that,
you know, that symphony of praise and and mercy.
Alhamdulillah. And then the response to
is
what
that may Allah guide you and may he make your a your you upright, right?
and and and and righteous and pious and
good.
I mean, what a what I mean, wai.
Someone just needs to sit there and reflect and write and talk about just this
beautiful interaction that plays out from from an innocuous event like a sneeze.
It it's and and when when when the prophet teaches us about the rights that we
have each other,
don't scoff at it.
say like
wait my right is that when I sneeze someone says something you just you can belittle
it you if you don't pay attention to what you're actually how you're thinking or your
attitude you may belittle it
but it's something very profound there's something very beautiful about the spirit that the prom wants
to be essentialized in the communal space
is that our shared narrative and our language is very beautiful is about the praise of
God it's about God's mercy it's about seeking guidance for each other
is that I am attentive to you because you have to be you have to have
wherewithal acknowledge someone's sneeze, you have to be
present
and you rush to, you know, you get them a tissue, you do that.
Why why is your attitude that way?
Because you're plugged into your brothers and your
sisters
and then when he falls ill, you visit them.
And there's much to be said about this endless endless amount from the things that I'll
say just to highlight is that the prophet in the where Allahh
says
oh my servant Allah says oh my servant I became sick and you did not visit
me. Of course
that language is
in a manner befitting to
Allahh
I was sick you not visit me.
So the the servant says ya ya Allah
yani
I I don't know you to become sick and I don't know like where do I
even come to visit you?
He said don't you know that my servant so and so was sick and if you
were to have visited soand so you would have found me
there
you would have found me with him with her the person who's sick.
So
from it for the base of it is that it's a right you know of your
brother or your sister who's sick
visiting them tending to them
from a perspective of right.
Now when you negotiate
rights
you're fulfilling their right not your desire.
Those are two different things.
You became sick.
I'm fulfilling your right.
So there are adab
there are requisite
uh um
there's a requisite decorum for how you visit someone who's
sick.
You're not you're not
heavy-handed. You express your wish and your desire in your will.
Maybe they're not super welcoming or inviting.
So you do that which replaces it.
Maybe drop off something small or something the cases or whatever.
You make it clear that this is a part of your concern of theirs.
And if so it was happen that you visit and you visit with it being a
very easy thing for them.
You come bearing some nice gifts, some simple belongings and you walk away 10 15 minutes.
You don't burden them.
So it's not for you, it's for them.
It's a right you're fulfilling.
And then the the the then the the the the reality that transpires is that when
you're in the company of the ill person, you're in the company of the divine.
That's what we're told.
When you're with someone who's sick, Allah is there.
That's where Allah is.
And those are very special sacred spaces, the spaces of
illness
for those who who understand and know.
And the lastly is when someone dies, you attend their
funeral. This is a right.
It's not just something you know um of course there's rewards for praying the janaza and
then following the janaza.
Each one has its reward
etc.
The next hadith inshallah
Um
yeah. So he says he mentions five
here.
The same five categories but mentioned
differently. Islam. The second thing that he mentions here is that greetings of peace are amongst
the best traits of Islam.
So he mentions here
um
so the prophetam said he was asked by
what is
which act of Islam is best?
Which act of Islam is best?
So the prophet sallallaihi wasallam says that you feed
people
and that you give greetings of peace to those that you know and those that you
do not know
that you spread salah.
So a proactive disposition of the believer if I want to have because the way abdah
does is he breaks it down within these categories for a reason.
So the number the first category is what?
It's a trust.
It's a right.
It's an it's a a right that a believer has.
The second category that he's mentioning is that it's a question of
the best Islam.
The best version of a Muslim is when they're feeding people.
The best version of a Muslim is when they say salam.
Those that they don't and those that they don't.
And this is something that I think we can all agree on.
We fall very short in the communal space.
And this is something we have to change about our religious uh communal
identity. Say salam make it our custom to say salam to everyone.
Someone who walks in, someone you know, someone you don't know, you say assalamu alaykum.
Doesn't matter. Say salamikum to as many people as you can.
Right? Because we're going to get to other narrations.
I'm not sure if we're going to get to them today.
But every time believers say salam and they shake hands, what happens when you shake a
believer's hands?
the sins just fall down like the leaves fall off the
tree.
So
the the sheer volume of virtue and beauty and goodness that happens in the space of
sending
salam,
if you could see the unseen, you would never miss saying salam to a believer ever.
If you only could see what was transpiring, what the angels are doing when you're sending
salam,
what they're reporting, what they're accounting for, the sins that are, you know, falling, endless, endless
virtues. So that's why says this
is
the best of Islam
is when you feed people and you say
salam.
What a beautiful religion we have.
We do. It's a very beautiful religion.
Yes.
Huh?
Yeah, that's a good question.
So, in terms of members of the opposite gender, what is the adab of saying salam?
So certainly it is not at the same proactive volume that should happen within the same
gender. So with men with men yes you're proactively looking for
um you know brothers or sisters or brothers who are coming in you're saying salam.
When it comes to opposite gender, it's it's usually when
you're passing each other by
and
um it's it's a it's a circumstance that you find yourself in.
Then yes, you say assalamu alaykum politely, you know, you you you you bow your head
in respect. You sayamikum.
You move on.
You don't stay silent.
Soalamu alaykum. You continue.
This could be you're at the mall, you're passing by someone.
Often people, you know, people get they don't know how to to respond because they're so
not accustomed to it.
I say salalamlaykum.
I was at the gas station.
I forgot where I was the other day.
Say salamkum.
Person
just just a
salam.
So, you know, but it's a it's a very great Yeah.
Don't get you know, so it's one thing when you're saying when a brother is saying
salam to a brother, it's a handshake.
It could be a
hug.
And there's we'll get to that as well, but I doubt we're going to get to
it today gi given the time where we are right now.
Um
that's obviously not going to happen between a male and a female.
So it's it's a far so it is it is
that when it comes to pass that you're in the presence of a brother or a
sister, you say salam
and and you progress and you move on.
That should not result in a very like engaged and involved interaction the way that members
of the same uh gender would.
Uh where am
I?
He said that.
Okay.
Hold on.
When did the prophetam say
this?
When did he say this?
And who is
Abdaham? Let's do a quick
quiz.
And if you get it right,
who here
will give you
something. If you get it right,
I'll give you a hug.
Just for
you,
not
you.
Who is Abdullah?
Yes, the rabbi.
The rabbi who became Muslim when the prophetam entered into Medina.
What was his name for an for an extra
$10?
He had a name and then the prophetam changed his name to
Abdullah.
His
name was Al
Hussein
Salam.
Al
Hussein. And then the man he came to the prophet wasallam.
He was a Jewish man who you know obviously the the the believers in Medina were
waiting waiting waiting.
And then when the prophetam finally
came
Abdullah went out he was from the tribe of he was from the the Yehood of
Bani.
And when he went out
and you know
So he's like I want to see too.
So he jumps out, he runs out, he sees.
So he narrates he says in the hadith
he says that
uh
when I saw him sallallahu alaihi
wasallam when I saw his
face
he says when I saw his face I
knew
that this is not the face of a liar.
And the first thing I heard him say
was
this is the first thing I heard.
So it was seeing the countenance of
hearing the first words he went straight to the prophetam
says
and the prophet who was your name he says
he says
abdah your name is Abdullah so the prophetam change and the prophetam would often change names
and he would usually change the names that he did not favor so for example there's
um a very common name amongst the Arabs was
harb
war.
It was a very common name because they loved, you know, they would name things because
of what they cherished.
They cherished warfare.
There's people today who cherish warfare.
They're obsessed with it.
That's all they exist for warfare.
Some psychotic, you
know,
regimes today, they exist for
warfare. And
so
the prophet did not exist for warfare.
And he did not like the name war.
So he would change everyone's name who was har
to
to peace.
Subhan
Allah.
So Abdaham
says that the first thing I heard the prophetam says when he walked into Medina was
spread and feed
people
and maintain the bonds of
kinship
and pray at night when people are
sleeping.
you will enter Jenna be salam
in
peace
and salam the
when they think about um the triilateral route of salah
you know and all of its
conjugations it's found in the
Quran
upwards of like 200 plus
times
you know Allahh says peace be upon you by that which you were patient with
you
know
enter into
So many ayat and hadith that
indicate that you know you enter into salam the abode of salam
you know
and
you know you are salam and from you is salam.
So the whole reality of the of the community of believers
is
is is the spread of salam of peace as a as an
integral essential identity of the community of believers.
It's what we exist and what we believe.
What we believe in intrinsically about community about space about
people.
That's the first thing the prophetam says when he entered into
Medina
and and for for us this has to become a mandate.
Really has to become a mandate.
And I'm not talking about it in the very
like
commercialized version of religion of peace stuff.
That's this like commercialized you know
like
peace peace is um
peace is a function
of
belief of
iman
you know of devotion of
conviction of mercy
of compassion of justice peace is a manifestation of many essential qualities that have to be
embedded in the communal sphere
and so for you when you say what does it mean to spread salam to spread
peace.
You have to think about it as a as a as a
ideal
as an injunction like what does it mean for me to be in a space
and peace is experienced because what the prophet wasallam one of the principal values that he
cultivated was a spirit of salam you felt safe that's why the prophetam
says
that the true believer is the one who others feel
safe
I feel safe that I know that I'm in your company.
I'm in a Muslim's company.
That's why I remember Imm Saraj,
may Allah bless him, you know, when he, you know, was first like him and the
community of believers around him in in in Brooklyn and Atlantic Atlantic Avenue, that community.
I mean it became the standard uh narrative of that society that if you want safety
and security and peace and wellness be around Imam Sajj and his
his brothers you know
and and because it was you felt safe and secure in their company
you know you felt well you did not
a Muslim should never create an environment around them with with Muslims or non-Muslims where they
where others feel you know
no you
you always feel that with a Muslim you're going to experience erience because
you know
um
Ibraim
he asked he
made
like the idea of safety and security of a land is so integral to the welfare
of a populace you know to be safe I mean look at the Palestinian people they
they never one day feel safe not one day for imagine for 80 years you've never
felt safe one day
I was listening to ex IDF soldiers
uh you know who who who who who who
talk about you know he's like I remember I was listening to one guy recently he
was like I I've been on 2,000
missions in the West Bank
and the only the mission was
you go into a random home at night.
The idea was we're going to surveil because we have to assess uh
threats, right?
But he's like
I I you know I'm I'm all masked up.
I'm geared up.
I break down the room.
I go in.
I grab the people from their beds.
throw them into a room, lock them in there, and then I'm supposed to be surveilling
from the window.
I did this 2,000 times.
And I
and he's like after
how many times I realized like all I'm doing is because the objective was just to
strike fear. It wasn't a matter of actual security.
It was just a matter of control.
That's what he said.
It wasn't a matter of actually, you know,
the security of their of the of his people.
So, you know, what kind of
What kind of world is it when you live when you're under the constant threat of
some harsh abuse, death, destruction, loss, theft?
Alhamdulillah. So the spirit and the nature of Islam is salam is that you create an
environment of salam of peace where you don't feel
or experience or have that
impact
you know. So, so to think of the objective of a follower of Snuhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam when the prophetam tells you
you have to think about what that actually means for you.
How that practically manifests in all factors of of of your
life.
So he
says
so feed people maintain the bonds of
kinship
then you'll enter Jenna be salam this is the principal heading of this chapter this section
which is that you will enter Jennah
that you will be
told
enter into
because of the salam that you exuded in this
life
Allah will tell you peace be upon you enter enter into
enter into the abode of peace.
So if you want access to peace from the divine then then be a man and
a woman of peace
in the truest prophetic sense of what that
means.
Uh
and then he says
So he says here he says that greetings of peace are among the means that to
enter paradise. We mentioned that that was number three.
The next one that he
mentioned is where he says that greetings of peace upon one's family
cause blessings to descend upon the household.
Timmad narrates on the authority of anus that the messenger of Allah wasallam told him my
little son when you meet your family give greetings of peace for your greetings of peace
will be a blessing for you and your household.
It was related by
who declared a sound per.
So he says here that from the sunnah of the prophet sallallaihi wasallam is that whenever
you enter your home you say salam.
And by the way the say even if your family is not home you still say
salam
because you're saying salam to the dwellers of the home and the angels and whoever may
be there.
So you're by you walk into your house
no one else is home.
You open up the
doorsum. That's becomes the spirit of because why do you s why do you do that?
because you're looking for the
baraka.
I I spoke about this in Ramadan.
If you are a baraka trader, you're in the tra you're in the trade of baraka,
then you'll look for it wherever you can get it.
When you walk into your home
and you walk in gently and kindly and you announce yourself, by the way, there's no
such thing of coming home unannounced.
You have to announce yourself.
You can't just bumrush the home.
You can't just, you know, um sneak up.
There's no sneak
attacks
on the home front.
I just want to know what was going on here.
You can't do that.
That's not the way of a believer.
You give you actually do the exact opposite.
You announce yourself so that if anyone is in a compromise situation, they fix
themsel. You understand that?
So this very devious act
that happens when people try to sneak up on someone else to catch them in the
act that's absolutely antithetical to the way of the prophetam what's your objective the gotcha
there's no goodness in get gotcha
a person is
in a compromised position situation whatever the case
is
between them and Allah subhana wa ta'ala
what's your business to catch them other than your nefs and your ego and their
police state mentality.
It's none of your
business. I'm
here.
Egyptians would
say
everyone wrap it up,
clean it up, put it together
just
why? Because you're a source of salam, not the other.
Like the prophetam in his in his hadith, he says, "Do not bang on doors like
policemen.
Prophetam says that
you don't bang on the door like a policeman.
Why is start?
It removes salam.
If you bang on doors, if you come in and announce, if you startle
someone. So do do not startle people.
Prophetam would not startle anyone.
Allah he would sall would not even startle insects and he would see a startled
chicken. Who who startled this chicken?
when he saw a bird fluttering because someone some of the companions took the eggs and
he
said
who who startled her
did not startle the creation of Allah.
So you don't
you don't you don't uh startle anyone.
There's no snooping.
There's no banging on doors.
There's announcement and there's assalamulaykum.
Why? Because you want the baraka to
descend. Is this clear?
Any lack of clarity on this?
Are yes.
Not for you.
No.
Listen. So when it comes to parents and
children, the difference is the only difference is that when the parent is responsible for their
child
and a parent and there's oversight, then the
parent
then there's there is an implicit agreement between the child and the parent meaning there's an
understanding not an agreement there's an understanding that your mother your father are overlooking your best
interest and until you are of age and competent and capable then you will have
you will be quote unquote
surveiled. I don't want to use that harsh word but like
you are being gently and lovingly over you know looked over.
It's very different.
So parents because of your interest, because of your self-interest, because of your welfare, because of
what's good for you, they will keep a watchful eye over you, right?
But once you're of age
and you are uh of a certain accountability in front of Allah subhana wa ta'ala and
there's now you are independently accountable and your parents responsibility in that regard is no longer
it's almost lifted from upon them, then yeah, then the same rules apply.
So when it comes to a young child and an older parent or their their parent
then
then you have to understand that they have a responsibility to seek your welfare.
Hope that's clear.
All the young kids are waking up.
All right, Dean.
What's going on here?
I'll let you know when you get
there.
That that age is fluid these days.
Let's let's just say,
you know, it could be
honestly, you know, all jokes aside,
it's
I would say the bare minimum is when you're 18.
Not because that's a number that's used, but that actually is a number from our tradition
that's used in many ways as well.
The Malikia used that number to indicate when a person is
uh when a person is
um
not
so I don't want to get too technical
saf
is not resp is not a responsible
actor
so that's a technical category in
Islami
because there's tech there's legal implications let's say money is left to you there's money left
to you
when do you have full access to that money to use as you're at at will.
Say you had a generous uh grandparent who says, "I love Dean a million dollars.
Do I give Dean a million dollars?"
No. No. There's a there's an age when you are uh
responsible. You're not all i.e.
you're outside of the the realm of saf
of foolishness where you can responsibly use that
money.
So that that's that age.
So it's not an exact number.
It's not an exact number.
It's more a state of being.
Is that clear?
That's a good question actually.
Good job, Dean.
Any other? No.
Great job, Noah.
Come on. Even better.
I mean, you guys are just competing for the
best.
Anyone else? You have a
question. Ibrahim Ibrahim has sworn never to ask a question in this class again.
Listen, I promise I'm going to be nice if you ask a
question. I mean, not 100% like I I semi promise.
Muhammad tell where were we?
Why do I keep on getting lost today?
According to
the messenger of Allah sallallahu alaihi wasallam said, "Worship the beneficient, spread
uh greetings of peace, feed people and you will enter the gardens of
Jenna."
Abu
Abuh says he requested the messenger of Allah sallallahu alaihi wasallam tell me of something that
ensures me paradise paradise he said sallallahu alaihi wasallam genial speech
offering reading greetings of peace
and feeding people
so
says
I want to be guarant guaranteed Jenna.
He said
uh
good words, good speech,
genial speech, offering greetings of peace and feeding
people.
Uh Abu Shar
is
he's a companion who became Muslim around the time of the conquest of Mecca.
And um one of the beautiful things about Abu Shar
about his hisl
his
character he would tell the companions listen to this because you see
how these companions when you actually tell likedam
when you know the backstory and you see what motivated him
the the hadith of peace are have become he's okay he's good he'll figure it
out
and you know you got to let them crawl fall climb explore
got
um
Abdullah a lot of the hadith of Salam
are associated are synonymous with him
if you find in the tradition and so you'll find this between the between the narrators
and the substance of the hadith often you'll find a lot of
because it seems to be like these are or characters or qualities that really color their
identity so they became you know synonymous with the transmission of this hadith.
So
he convert he became a Muslim during the conquest of Mecca and so he's coming and
he's saying Allah
um you know give me that which ensures me paradise.
So the prophetam says good speech and offering greetings and feeding people.
So
he would tell the companions proactively listen to this.
He says if any of you find or see
or know that I possess milk or s or um ghee like
butter
then it is yours without any
ask.
So if you hear or you know that for example this milk is ab
or this ghee this butter is abush
then you use it without
any request or ask it's
yours.
Why? Because he wants Jenna.
You know these are the traitors.
These are like the traitors of baraka.
Subhan
Allah.
You know from the people from the qualities of the people of Jenna is that you
pour that which is in your cup and their cup.
So you have something for example you have a lot of juice and they have no
juice. You pour your juice into their cup.
You spouses should do this with each other all the time.
Preferring each other in food and drink is from the qualities of the people of Jenna.
You know, um, you you got a lot of candy
in Eid
and you got a little bit of candy,
you give candy to them.
You you you
you
displace, you make it that they have equal amount of candy,
right?
Yes.
There you
go.
Um,
according to the narration, he said, "Oh messenger of Allah, guide me to an act that
will admit me into paradise."
He said among what ensures forgiveness are offering greetings of peace and genial
speech.
So you
know
is is
nice good gentle genial speech
very loosely put
like just someone whose tongue is pleasant they have good things to say.
The prophetam
says
if you believe in Allah in the in the last day then say good or remain
quiet.
By the way a lot the the
um
imandi
he says that he says imandi
says that
one of the
major causes of fitan is frivolous speech meaningless speech.
I have no doubt that the volume of nonsense that's mentioned and spoken about in
on social media causes so much distress, so much emotional disturbance, psychological disturbance.
Really, I mean, you always feel
bad
when you're just
consuming non
speech. It's just ugly.
It's
so the
believer
and
the the principle of it is that it reminds you of Allah.
It brings you closer to the prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
When I was in I when I was in Morocco, I visited the uh some of
the
like the
bedins
with one of my sh
and
we went there and we arrived.
It was like maybe
6:00 p.m. or so.
Allah is my witness.
From 6:00 p.m.
until
there was not
one
word
mentioned outside of
Quran,
dua
vik
hadith,
nothing. Not one word
after
faj
after fudge. And and by the way, from 6 PM until 2 am,
it was
like beautiful
uh
nasheed and and songs and poems
and it was breaks for like reminders of like a of the some hadith maybe someone
recite Quran for a little bit.
That was the
like that was the welcoming and it lasted until 2 a.m.
2 a.m. Okay, get some rest.
After fudge, we prayed fudge did somear and then it was like how are you doing?
What's your name?
I was amazed.
I was like, what?
I've never like they literally the volume of speech was designated to
the purest form of
goodness. That's what it is.
Like the words of Allah, the words of the prophetam and then the words that are
about Allah and the words that are about the prophet
and
then
we'll talk shop.
What's your name?
What's my name?
Who are you?
Where are you from?
what's your
and so you know it was what was amazing to me about that experience was there
was a guy I remember who was sitting right in front of me I by the
way I can give a whole lecture just about that event that gathering it was one
of the most
eyeopening experiences of my life from start to finish but that's a very long story that
I can get into another time some of you have heard like bits and pieces of
it
anyway
I recall there was a guy who was sitting in front of me he was in
charge of the uh uh the tea you know the Moroccan tea so he had this
like he has this whole set up ready to go and he's like boiling water and
you know it's a very specific method that they use and
you know you know
so he's so he's done with this whole he's working the whole
time
after fudge when we're going to we're getting to know each other very gently like of
course the elders first and then like everyone when you're asked you don't you're not talking
out of line when you're asked who you are then you say well my name is
so and so and that's all you say unless someone asks you what are you what
do you do
so he's asked by one of Sh, what's your name?
Oh, I'm so and so.
What do you do?
He turns out to be like the attorney assist like like an assistant district attorney or
something like he's no like small guy, but he was sitting making tea the entire night.
Like I thought he was just, you know, quote unquote, you know, someone is in his
spirit.
But I said, subhan Allah, like you look at the culture that
essentializes just good words.
You know what?
How beautiful would our homes and our gatherings be
if essential in them were the the speech of Allah, the speech of the prophet sallall
alaihi wasallam than the speech about Allah and his messenger Muhammad wasallam and thear that that
becomes the primary form of communication that that we share.
May Allah gift us and grant
us.
It's five
o'clock. Man, I I need to move quicker.
I have a problem.
I think they say the first,
you know, the first step in in in healing is acknowledging you have a problem.
I think I have to officially say I have a problem, guys.
I don't know how to fix it.
I want to get through so much more, but you know, may Allah help
me.
It's 5:00. Should I break for for Q&A?
I'll be respectful
questions. If you say no, I'll just jump back into
Yes, I'm up.
What was that?
Play for P for what?
Hugs
with you. Amar 100%.
There's no doubt in my mind if you hug
amili
the angels will carry you to
Jenna.
So we know that for we know that for shaking hands
definitively. We also know that the companions when they would come back from travel they would
hug.
All right. That's why there's actually a discussion amongst
the
uh about hugging in particular.
Is hugging a regular act amongst
believers or shaking?
So shaking definitely there's a difference of opinion on hugging.
It's a very interesting conversation.
I don't know if I want to open this door right now.
Let's just say the Malikia are of the opinion that less hugging is better
between
men.
I maybe I'll leave it at
that.
So this is the discussion there's discussion about but but I would say the handshake definitively
that because there's a specific narration about that.
We do know that when the companions traveled, after travel, they would hug each
other.
Yes, sister in the
back.
For women, yes, the same rules apply.
Yeah,
but I'm not saying don't hug.
I I did not say that.
Did I say that?
I did not say that.
Is the handshake superior to the hug?
You putting you want to put me in dangerous waters.
Listen, I just want to tell you what the prophet said and that's it.
Oh, was that the question?
So
the the the the the Malikis seem to discourage hugging
outside of travel, outside of like big moments of so they don't essentialize it
as a common greeting
practice.
But that is that is the Malik that is like the Maliki position in terms of
this
and they have their rationale and their reasoning and there's a whole discourse around the
but I'm not saying that to say don't hug you know if a part of your
cultural practice or your routine or whatever the case is is to hug then you know
do not stop that because of
I didn't give the official ruling
I just was reflecting on like so so certainly we know shaking hands
it should be a proactive act so you should
increase the volume of people
obviously man man woman woman who of the pe the hands that you shake you should
certainly increase the volume of that.
Yes.
I feel like
personally started.
Yeah.
So I I I think that I think you have to distinguish between a few things.
So certainly yes when someone increases in knowledge then naturally they feel
that they can be more
opinionated they have more
uh they have stronger opinions you know because you feel like oh now I possess some
knowledge something that you don't have so I see I look in a particular way that
you don't look I see I see things that you don't see so there there could
be
that certainly with the increase of knowledge something happens to you
um that makes you
uh more judgmental etc.
And that's why Omar says he has a very famous statement.
He says,
pay attention to this.
He
says,
did you get
that?
So he says,
you know,
learn knowledge, study knowledge, grow in your knowledge and for your knowledge, learn
forbearance. We spoke about forbearance here.
I think pretty extensively we definitely define what that looks like and feels like.
So he's saying for your knowledge also learn with your knowledge learn forbearance with your knowledge
so that your knowledge is beautiful so that your knowledge is grateful so that your knowledge
is meaningful so that it doesn't become a sword that it doesn't become a double-edged sword
that then cuts you
because
increase in knowledge can easily be make you delusional, arrogant, aggressive, condescending, judgmental.
many diseases of the heart that can come about from knowing
something. So that's something you have to be aware.
The second thing I would say is that whatever you may think you
know
there are those who know much more than you and then there's principally Allah who knows
all things because he
is
so whatever you may think you know you know nothing
truthfully and that's why he
says
the more I increase in knowledge the more increase in the knowledge of my ignorance that
I know nothing and the true people of knowledge are those who acknowledge that they know
nothing that's the true person of knowledge that I
they they in their now it doesn't mean that they're ignores
no there's someone you go and you seek their fatwa and whatever but they in themselves
do not conceive themselves of possessing knowledge because they know the reality of knowledge
now
so if with your knowledge there's arrogance or judgmentalism whatever know that you're an
know that you are you know beyond an infant in knowledge if you are a true
person of knowledge you would have a very different
disposition Um,
yeah, those are some things I'll share.
Does that answer your question?
Okay, great. Leave it at that.
Questions? Yes.
Yeah.
Well, did I say he overlooked mistakes?
Did I say that?
No, I don't remember.
I don't think I ever said he overlooked mistakes.
No, no, no, it's
okay.
So, he he he he didn't overlook, but he
absorbed with forbearance to guide and teach.
It's two different things.
So may you may absorb a shortcoming like for example this man who urinated he absorbed
the shortcoming but to get to the ultimate point of bringing him in settling him down
and then teaching him.
So the prophetam never
um deprived someone of of guidance or a right of of
advice. Never he never deprived them.
uh the prophetam's one of his principal concerns
was
did I convey the message this is what he was saying in the final
uh
um
in his in his final sermon the prophetam kept on
saying
did I convey did I relay did all of you get the message
you know then and And
then
you have conveyed he says you know
oh Allah bear witness.
So his biggest concern was that he was conveying the message.
So he never deprived anyone.
Now
I
the
the idea that the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam it's okay have you leave fine he's fine
he's mama wants
okay
the the idea that the prophet wasallam would absorb had
forbearance two different things.
Now practically speaking for
us
someone who you know a friend of yours is making mistakes okay
and you know that they're making mistakes and you want to advise them the question is
how do you go about doing it
you you number one purify your intention number two make dua for
them
then in in the best time and window you advise them
be gentle and kind and
one two and three times as makes sense as and sensible but once it gets to
a point where the advice
is having the adverse effect
that you then you withhold the advice because you don't want to drive them further away.
Doesn't make any sense anymore.
By the way, uh back to the question on just as a quick side note, someone
came up to me with an important question in during the break which was around the
children and prayer and the question of like the gentle hit or whatever the case is
uh the gentle
tap.
The
say something very important around the concept of
that I think people miss and don't appreciate.
The
say
if
that type of
reproach results in the
um adverse
effect.
So let's say the the the the method that you're using to
uh to discipline or to punish is resulting in the adverse
desired outcome. the the the opposite of the desired outcome, then that method becomes obsolete.
You don't use it because the objective is
that if this type of discipline results in
the the the
good outcome that you're seeking.
But if it doesn't have that desired outcome, then you don't use it.
So
it's a tool.
It's not an objective.
You understand? So when the prophet says
it doesn't mean
that you have to hit.
No, he's not saying you have to hit them.
He's not that's not what he's indicating categorically.
He's saying if it comes to it and it's an effective tool then you use it.
If it's not effective then what's the point or if it leads them to further them
away from prayer then we didn't it's having the adverse effect.
So is this this is an important principle around
that in the in the tradition.
I just want to
highlight last questions inshallah.
I think we're we're we're wrapping
up
hopefully inshallah the next class will get
is it announced we okay
when you announce in next next class I'll
this is a ongoing series by the way one of the reasons why the team made
an ongoing series is out of mercy and compassion with me
because all the other classes they see me like they're pressuring me to get through a
book you have to finish the book by I'm like guys don't do that to
me
so this way the the book is with us we live with Abdaham
May Allah make us of those who truly live like the prophet.
And I pray all this time that we spend together that we really internalize these values
that we become people of
the people of of gentleness and kindness that we become a people of salam in all
of its manifestations inwardly and outwardly.
May we be at peace inwardly.
May I be at peace outwardly and may we generate peace in our our community and
our society. May we truly be represent truly be representatives of
sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
Inshallah we'll see you next time whenever that is.
Yeah.